hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll
physics it is in a crisis we are told
this I've been told this on the internet
on podcasts even in books the crisis
that we're in in physics right now and
that's sad to be to hear the physics is
in a crisis I grew up wanting to be a
physicist I nem now a physicist among
other things physics is my life I love
it very much it makes me worry to hear
that the field would be in a crisis what
does that mean did the laws of physics
stop working did physicists go on strike
what exactly is going on so I am here to
do this solo podcast to tell you my
particular views on the crisis in
physics which is that there is not a
crisis in physics that is what I think
anyway I will give you my reasons for
thinking that you can make up your own
mind I first want to say though that it
makes me sad that I have to be on that
side you know what I was going showing
up thinking about being a physicist I
certainly imagined that in the fantasy
future life I had for myself I would be
a radical physicist a heretic right
tearing down the stuffy establishment
Notions and replacing them with my own
creative impulse and so forth and it
took quite a bit of education and years
and thinking to realize that being a
heretic is super hard work it's really
really very difficult you know the
Heretics who are out there will often
point to people like Galileo and
Einstein as their predecessors in heresy
what they don't tell you all the time is
that nobody understood the physics of
their time better than Galileo and
Einstein these people maybe had
opposition from The Establishment
absolutely no doubt about that they
would Grumble about that opposition
sometimes but if they did overthrow the
established view it was very much from
working inside the system they first
mastered what everyone else understood
and they built upon it and building upon
it sometimes means tearing something
down and building something better it's
not that they just wandered in off the
street with their own kooky ideas and
succeeded
in the real world of the history of
science especially in fields that are
mature Fields where we understand the
basic ideas in many different ways where
there are a lot of established results
Etc it's really really hard to be a good
heretic even though it is romantic and
attractive I would like to be the
heretic but then I look out at the
information landscape at what people are
being told about physics and what I find
is there is far too much heresy out
there it is far too easy for the person
on the street who just wants to know
what the universe is like to hear the
point of view of The heretical Fringe
rather than the establishment uh just
the other week we heard a paper that
came out with a press release claiming
that the universe is really twice as old
as anyone thought it was complete and
utter nonsense sadly but people who
really should know better jumped on that
as evidence that ah see cosmologies not
really as settled as we think anything
could happen I've been skeptical all
along I have had my suspicions and now I
see them confirmed right but it's it's
just nonsense it was just crack pottery
and so I feel that my own job is
something different you know I've
mentioned before that I've heard this
podcast
criticized for not being edgy enough and
I wear that as a badge of honor my goal
is never to be edgy maybe it will be
edgy by mistake or because that's where
we go but my goal is to be correct or at
least my goal is to help you the
listener and me the podcaster in our
mutual goals of becoming more and more
correct more and more right about the
real world
sometimes that involves being edgy and
creative and rebellious and heretical
sometimes it involves understanding why
the establishment has the point of view
that it does so in the solo podcast I
want to cover what I think about the
claims that physics is in crisis right
now I'm not going to pick on individual
people because that's not what we're
here about I'm going to pick on
individual ideas and what I think is
true is that because I do want to give
you the ability to make up your own mind
whether or not you agree with me
in order to understand whether physics
in crisis it's necessary to understand
where physics is so a lot of this I
predict overly long podcast is going to
be me trying to explain the basics of
how we got here and where we are right
now which is a lot but I think it's kind
of worth it so maybe the people who are
experts in modern physics will find this
a bit of a review for most of the
podcast but hopefully we'll shed light
for those of you who are not in the
trenches here
let me take this opportunity before we
dive into it to mention that we have a
patreon you knew I was going to say that
right
patreon.com Sean M Carroll is where you
go to give support to the mindscape
podcast I mentioned on Twitter and I
should mention again that we've been
experimenting with this new thing where
at the end of every podcast I do a
little reflection video so video or
audio either way you can listen to it me
just for a couple of minutes saying what
I thought about the podcast or
explaining why I had that particular
guest on Etc I have put up one example
on the YouTubes if you go to my YouTube
channel it's not hard to find Sean
Carroll uh it might be Sean M Carroll
who knows but you can find it you're
very smart you will find a little free
sample I I showed up or I put on YouTube
the reflection video I did after the Tim
Maudlin podcast if you want to see the
basic Spirit of what it is like I don't
do reflection videos for the ask me
anything episodes that would be too much
of my own voice but I figure for this
solo episode maybe I will do a lore
reflection video maybe I will reveal
some secrets that you don't get to hear
if you're a patreon supporter who knows
you know are you willing to take that
chance that's the real question and with
that let's go
[Music]
foreign
a good place to start talking about the
crisis in physics is in a tweet from
Martin Bauer Marty's a very good
physicist and a very good Twitter follow
if you are still following people on
Twitter before it completely dies I
encourage you to follow Martin M Bauer
and what Martin says is he says the
crisis in particle physics he found an
article which he thinks is accurately
and intriguingly portraying the crisis
that we have in particle physics or
fundamental physics and so he goes over
in what ways the crisis is manifesting
itself it is that high energy
theoretical physics is in trouble
because it's become too specialized
because there is no clear theory that is
leading the pack and going to win the
day because physicists are willing to
wander away from what the data are
telling them focusing on speculative
ideas that the system suppresses
independent thought that theorists are
not interacting with experimental
experimentalists and so on there's a
long list now I've been in this
discourse too long for a long time so I
knew but by the time I was you know the
at the third or fourth tweet in this
thread I kind of figured out the joke
and the joke is at the very end Martin
reveals that indeed all these quotes are
from a very long like hundred page
article on the crisis in particle
physics from the year 1977.
that's the joke
because everyone always thinks that
their field isn't a crisis right or at
least there's a certain kind of person
who will always think their field is in
a crisis no matter what state it's
actually in to many of us now looking
back the mid-1970s are like the golden
days of particle physics and Quantum
field Theory right we were finally
figuring out gauge theories and
confinement and the standard model and
chiral Symmetry and things like that and
uh instantons not perturbative you can
go on and on like the 70s or the Golden
Age and here's this person making all
the same complaints about the state of
physics that we are hearing about it now
so how can this be true and how should
we think about what it means right now
because you are hearing uh
people who are pretty respectable as
well as completely fringy lunatics
complain about the current state of
physics and one thing I want to say is
that even though I am going to be a
little bit of an apologist for the
current state of physics I'm certainly
not going to be a complete apologist I
have my issues and I would like to
criticize physics and the physics
Community I'm happy to do that but I
want to do it in a nuanced way and when
I for example let's take the foundations
of quantum mechanics right you will have
heard me say that it is a shame and
embarrassment a scandal that the
foundations of quantum mechanics are so
thoroughly ignored by the physics
Community but what you won't hear me say
is it it's because there's a conspiracy
because they are afraid of their cushy
positions because even because they're
not working in good faith they're too
afraid to face the truth none of those
things am I going to say what I'm going
to say is they're wrong the physics
establishment is wrong to not Place more
emphasis on understanding the
foundations of quantum mechanics and
here are my intellectual reasons why
they are wrong I'm not trying to
question their morals or their
intentions or their integrity I'm trying
to give a better argument and that's
fine and so I'm gonna try to give a good
argument throughout this podcast about
the ways in which I think that we can do
better than what we're doing right now
in contemporary fundamental physics but
most of it I'm just going to be saying
here is why we are doing it in this
particular way and it actually kind of
makes sense
so the big big reason why we're in so
much apparent trouble in physics is
because physics is too successful this
is the irony someone should come up with
a fancy name for this particular uh
ironic situation we find ourselves in
physics for the first time in human
history is too good at understanding the
physical world and I want to be very
very specific about what that means
because there's certainly plenty of
things we don't understand right but we
understand a lot and that is getting us
into trouble as physicists because
progress or even the illusion of
progress is easier to perceive when
we're not done yet right when there's
things that we don't understand that are
staring us right in the face and we can
try to come up with explanations and
test them right away that's not the
situation we're in right now but let's
be careful about this you know in
addition to my physics job I am now a
professional philosopher so I'm
I'm uh what obligated to be careful
about defining my terms and things like
that so when I say that physics
understands things what do I mean you
know there's there's a certain kind of
response that I'm just going to dismiss
because it's a misunderstanding what I'm
trying to say when I say like we
understand gravity uh Einstein in 1915
gave us general relativity it fits all
the data it made predictions they all
came true it's it's well understood and
there are people who will say yeah but
we don't really understand Gravity Man
like what is space-time okay you know I
I get that I'm not sure that there is
necessarily a sensible answer to that
one but it's not what I mean okay so I'm
just putting that aside by me talking
about understanding what I mean is we
have some well-defined physical theory
that fits all the data and we think is
accurate and true in its domain of
applicability so let me be even more
specific than that we we can distinguish
between different levels of
understanding that a physicist would
recognize we can we can talk about what
you might want to label strong
understanding a strong understanding is
what we have for example with general
relativity there's a unique well-tested
Theory it accounts for all of the data
that we have within the purported domain
of applicability of the theory so the
theory might say well I just don't know
what to say about something so general
relativity doesn't know what to say
about the singularity in a black hole or
the Big Bang or you know small-scale
quantum gravity stuff but in the regime
where general relativity purports to
make predictions all those predictions
are 100 compatible with the data as far
as we know right now and there are no
real competitors right there's no people
working on alternatives to general
relativity that would truly displace
general relativity there are plenty of
people including myself who've worked on
modifications of general relativity
extensions and so forth Worth or even
theories that would underlie general
relativity in some sense but general
relativity will still be there it will
always be there it is just like when we
talk about Newtonian gravity or
Newtonian Dynamics the fundamental
ontology you know the fundamental deep
down framework of what that theory took
to be real and important turns out not
to be there right we don't have an
absolute space absolute time action at a
distance any of those features of
Newtonian gravity
but the theory remains accurate in its
domain of applicability so Newtonian
gravity didn't go away if you want to
fly a rocket to the moon or catch a
baseball Newtonian gravity is the theory
for you so General relativities like
that it's not going to go away that is
what I am labeling a strong
understanding at the level of physics
then we might talk about weak
understanding okay we have a weak
understanding when there are situations
for which we have more than one Theory
we have several theories that in
principle can account for the data but
at the moment we cannot discriminate
between them plenty of examples of this
okay
um you know a really good example
actually is quantum mechanics the
foundations of quantum mechanics that's
the conundrum we find ourselves in
back in the 1920s we didn't actually
have any single very good theory in
quantum mechanics we had some ad hoc
rules that grew into what we call the
Copenhagen interpretation
but starting in the 50s with bohomian
mechanics and many worlds and then also
objective collapse models Etc we have
now a handful a perfectly good physical
theories that all give the same
predictions in the data that we have so
far collected we can hope and in some
cases it's clearly true that there will
be deviations in their predictions down
the line but so far in the data we've
actually made these theories make the
same predictions so that's a weak
understanding we we kind of have
theories that might be right but we
don't know if any one of them is right
or we don't know which one is right or
even if the one that will turn out to be
right is one that we haven't invented
yet that's also true not just for
quantum mechanics but for other famous
examples like in cosmology Dark Matter
Dark Energy these are things that
cosmologists talk about all the time and
you have to be a little bit careful
when you talk about how well we
understand these things it is too easy
to say well 95 of the universe is
something we don't understand at all
that's just wrong that that's not
something that you should say 95 of the
universe which is the 70 that is dark
energy the 25 that is dark matter are
things that we haven't pinpointed yet
but that is very very different from
saying that we don't understand them at
all on the one hand we know an enormous
amount about their properties we know
how much dark matter and dark energy
there is we know where it is we know how
it behaves to a very good approximation
and we have multiple theories that could
account for what is going on in both
cases for dark matter we have wimps and
axions and plenty of other ideas for
Dark Energy we have the vacuum energy
the cosmological uh the cosmotional
constant which is the same as the vacuum
energy also dynamical quintessence-like
fields and so forth but we don't know
which if any of those are right so I
would qualify that as a weak kind of
understanding there's something that we
understand about the phenomenon we have
more than one theory that can fit the
data but we have not yet figured out
which if any of those theories is right
and then there are cases where there's
no understanding so neither strong nor
weak understanding right we don't have
any solid theories that account for the
data a classic example right now in
modern physics would be what happened at
the Big Bang we just don't know what
happened before the Big Bang is there
even before a big bang we just don't
know we have to be honest we have kind
of hand wavy models again I'm
responsible for some of them but we
don't have anything that rises to the
level of a completely convincing theory
that you know if we discovered a wimp or
an Axion tomorrow you go oh yeah okay
good that's the answer we've been
waiting to figure it out now we know it
there is no such theory on the market
now which even if we found evidence for
it when it comes to what happened at the
Big Bang we would instantly jump on that
bandwagon because the theories are half
baked they're in the situation where
maybe quantum mechanics was in 1925 or
something like that and
the history is that most of the time in
the history of physics there were big
obvious things you could point to where
we had no understanding things that were
very well within the realm of
experimentally accessible phenomena you
know today we say the Big Bang is
something about which we have no
understanding but you can't see the big
bang either right it's very long time
ago and more importantly there is the
when I talk about the Big Bang now I
mean literally the moment okay not the
Big Bang model the Big Bang model is
what happens over the next 14 billion
years as the universe expands and cools
from an initially hot dense State and
galaxies coalesce all that is a Big Bang
model that's in 100 good shape what
happened at the moment of the Big Bang
is something we have no understanding
about but it is precisely because of
features right after the purported
initial moment that kind of make it hard
to see what happened at that moment the
universe basically is is locally in
thermal equilibrium it's not really in
thermal equilibrium because the universe
is expanding but the hot dense plasma is
you know kind of featureless there's not
a lot there there's a little bit there
of course we look at the temperature
fluctuations in the cosmic microwave
background we learn a lot from them but
not as much as we would like and
certainly nothing that gives us direct
evidence about what happened at the Big
Bang what I'm trying to get at in
telling you all this is to contrast it
to what the story would have been like
100 years ago right 100 years ago we
knew about protons and neutrons and
nuclei but we had zero idea what held
those nuclei together we had no
understanding at all what we would Now
call the strong and weak nuclear forces
a hundred years before that we didn't
know what light was we thought it was a
wave but we didn't have Maxwell's theory
of electromagnetism to tell us it was a
wave in the electromagnetic field with
equations and all that stuff okay and of
course even easier claims to point to
earlier in the history of physics so the
overwhelming story of the history of
physics is there's certain things that
we had some understanding of but very
obvious pointable to phenomena phenomena
that we did not have any understanding
of at all and we were working on that we
were trying to come up with theories to
explain that and the real weird thing
about the present moment is that we have
at least a weak understanding in some
cases a strong understanding of
everything that we are able to
experimentally
probe directly okay we have a strong
understanding of everything nearby so as
I very often said the laws of physics
underlying everyday life are completely
understood but what I mean by that is
you and all the atoms you're made out of
and all the forces holding them together
and pushing them around as well as
everyone else you've ever met and the
floor you're walking on and the air
around you and the sun shining and the
Earth and the moon and the stars all of
that we have a strong understanding we
have a theory that is right that
explains what's going on there and we
have at least a weak understanding of
every experimentally accessible
phenomenon we don't understand as I said
uh dark matter and dark energy at the
strong level we have a weak
understanding of them but there's sort
of nothing
that is experimentally accessible to
which we have no understanding at all
that's new that is a new feature in the
history of physics so I wanted to if you
will indulge me explain how we got there
a little bit this is going to be sketchy
because it's basically the whole history
of physics right or at least of modern
physics
um Let me let me
pause before I dive into it to mention
what other things I don't want to forget
to say it
you know we had the 1920s in physics
um it was a pretty remarkable decade it
wasn't just quantum mechanics that came
together but there were you know uh
really important experiments and
radioactivity and things like that not
to mention the discovery of the
expansion of the universe and if as a
whole you think about the first half of
the 20th century okay the between the
years 1900 which very conveniently was
the year that Planck put forward his
hypothesis of discrete packets of energy
being given off in black body radiation
which launched eventually into quantum
mechanics
to 1950 where you know we had built the
atomic bomb I forgot to mention in the
intro you know if you've seen
Oppenheimer recently you know that
physics does matter for our everyday
lives as well as for intellectual lives
that's an enormous amount happened over
the first half of the 20th century we
invented special relativity general
relativity quantum mechanics Quantum
field Theory particle physics the Big
Bang model the expansion of the universe
all this stuff okay
it was an absolutely unique era in the
history of physics it was so much stuff
going on that in the second half of the
20th century when we think about
fundamental physics let me pause once
again sorry about this again something I
forgot I should write better notes for
these solo episodes but I forgot to say
this also
to the extent that they're supposed to
be a crisis in anything it's not in
physics it's in a particular Little
slice of physics what you might call
fundamental physics high energy physics
uh particle physics something like that
okay
um there's plenty of other areas of
physics that are going on just fine with
nothing even arguably crisis like about
them whether it's plasma physics or
Atomic physics or molecular physics or
biophysics or even astrophysics for that
matter condensed matter physics soft
knest matter hardkiness matter whole
bunches of things that are going along
just fine more you know fun discoveries
than ever so when people try to say that
there's a crisis in physics they're
showing that they're a little bit uh
favoring in their attentions a certain
kind of physics now that happens also be
my kind of physics so I do care about
that but there's a simple glib answer to
the crisis and physics question which is
you got to pay more attention to the
rest of physics but still it's important
that fundamental physics be uh
understood and hopefully moving forward
so that's what we're talking about in
this podcast today so
as I was saying about the second half of
the 20th century in fundamental physics
it was a very exciting time black holes
were thought about and discovered uh we
put together the standard model of
particle physics and we built these
giant particle accelerators and
discovered all these wonderful particles
we
um found the acceleration of the
universe in 1998 but
thinking back on it now since we're no
longer quite in that half century an
argument could be made I'm not sure how
good an argument it is but I think it's
a it's a plausible one face value
um
believable that all the excitement of
the second half of the 20th century in
fundamental physics was really cleaning
up and finishing the project of the
first half of the 20th century you know
the first half of 20th century we
already had quantum mechanics and
Quantum field theory in some sense
putting together the standard model was
just figuring out what is the right
Quantum field Theory to actually
describe the world we already had
general relativity in some sense
figuring out that there were black holes
and the cosmic microwave background and
things like that was really taking
general relativity seriously in
understanding what it predicted it was
by all possible measures and enormously
exciting time in physics the second half
of the 20th century but it was also very
much building on the excitement of the
first half of the 20th century you know
we talked about the fact that people
always find that their own era is in
crisis or whatever Richard Feynman who
we now think of as this you know
brilliant very important foundational
physicist kind of lamented that he
wasn't around for the real excitement in
the 1920s right but anyway it was a very
exciting time and a lot of progress was
made in the second half of the 20th
century now we're in the first half of
the 21st Century
and the going is getting a little bit
slower because because at the very
simplest level
we finished cleaning up and putting the
dots on the eyes and crossing the t's of
the tremendous Revolutions of the first
half of the 20th century and the reason
why I want to emphasize this is because
that first half of the 20th century
isn't what we should expect
we were spoiled it's usually not that
much going on at the same time not quite
so many revolutions per decade in
fundamental physics I think actually If
we're honest even though I have made and
will continue to make this argument that
we're in a slightly special situation
right now because we have a theory that
fits all the data if you put aside the
actual theories that we have and just
think about the rate of progress I think
that right now we're in a much more
typical rate of progress in fundamental
physics than we uh were in the 20th
century especially that first half so we
have to sort of you know
accept that it's not always going to be
like the first half of the 20th century
that was a very special historic time
maybe there will be times in the future
that are equally exciting but my point
is that you can't just rely on it to be
that exciting every single half century
okay
that was a little background but now I
want to go through the specifics I want
to be a little bit more specifics about
what this understanding is that we
currently have because that's going to
be important for understanding why
it's so hard to move beyond that
understanding so we have space time
right and again we're very very sketchy
you're not going to learn this in any
comprehensive comprehensive way from
this particular podcast but we have the
idea that space and time are glued
together to make space time this was the
theory of relativity Einstein but again
the finishing touches on it in 1905
arguably maybe the Finishing Touch was
1907 when minkowsky pointed out that you
should think of special relativity as a
theory of space-time Einstein was
reluctant to go along with that but he
eventually realized that was a very good
idea that he was building Einstein was
building on progress that had been made
at the end of the 19th century and even
before 1905 people like Lorenz and
Fitzgerald and juanqueray and and so
forth had really shaped up a lot of what
you needed the ingredients were there to
put them together into the theory of
special relativity and it was minkowsky
who really said think of this as a
theory of space-time and then in 1915
Einstein Who Would by that point very
much come on the bandwagon of thinking
about space and time as unified rather
than separate as they were in Newtonian
physics said and space-time can be
curved and it's that curvature that is
gravity and that was the theory of
general relativity both of these
theories special and general relativity
survive to the present day special
relativity is the theory of how
space-time is when gravity is not
important when the curvature of
space-time is essentially flat general
relativity is a theory that includes
gravity makes predictions like the big
bang black holes and so forth
the next ingredient is quantum mechanics
again the first hints in that very turn
of the century but it wasn't really made
quantitative in a convincing way until
the 1920s with Matrix mechanics from
Heisenberg and his friends Wade
mechanics from Schrodinger the
Copenhagen interpretation was eventually
dominant it came to be the way that
people thought about quantum mechanics
you've heard me mention that we're not
done yet with quantum mechanics as
Einstein also thought at the time but
I'm not going to go into that here I
just point out the quantum mechanics you
know if anything it's super impressive
how quickly people jumped on the quantum
bandwagon if you if you go from 1900 to
1927 1927 is the year of the fifth
Solvay conference which is sort of the
really
uh solidification of our contemporary
understanding of quantum mechanics given
the absolutely revolutionary nature of
what quantum mechanics is and how much
of a departure it was from the Newtonian
Paradigm which had been incredibly
successful up to those up to then I give
just immense credit to the physicists of
the time who were willing to throw out
so much that had been successful the
whole Paradigm of deterministic
laplacian evolution that had been set up
by Newton and replace it with quantum
mechanics oh anyway kudos to them I
think the history will recognize that
they don't they don't need my help but
then of course this Quantum field Theory
I have to emphasize that Quantum field
theory is not a successor to Quantum
Mechanics you know sometimes this is a
little bit confusing so quantum
mechanics is a replacement for classical
mechanics okay but it is a framework in
which you can study many different kinds
of systems the harmonic oscillator spins
what have you
field theory is just one of those
systems that you can study within the
framework of quantum mechanics and
Quantum field theory is precisely the
quantum theory of fields it is a quantum
theory it is underneath the umbrella of
quantum mechanics it is not separate
from it or a replacement to it and
Quantum field theory is one hundred
percent compatible with special
relativity
it is marginally compatible with general
relativity I'll get to that in a second
but you know sometimes people say is it
possible to reconcile special relativity
with quantum mechanics and you have to
say yes that was done in the 1930s
basically right so you gotta catch up
yes relativistic Quantum field theory is
our best current understanding of
fundamental physics and it 100 includes
the lessons of special relativity
and the whole point of quantum field
theory is to say that there aren't
particles out there right
um the world is made of fields
fundamentally whether you're talking
about photons and gravitons from the
electromagnetic field in the
gravitational field or whether you're
talking about electrons and neutrinos
and quarks those are all based on fields
that is to say something that fills all
of space-time takes on a value at every
point in space-time and has some
Dynamics they can vibrate they can
oscillate and we perceive those
oscillations as particles because why
because quantum mechanics it is exactly
the same kind of mathematical thing
going on when you look at an emission of
photons from an atom right the whole
thing that inspired the original Quantum
Revolution one of the things was that
the wavelengths of light coming out of
atoms are quantized are discrete certain
kinds of frequencies are seen others are
not you see spectral lines why because
the electrons fall into orbitals that
have different discrete energies and
what you're seeing when you see those
emissions from atoms is an electron
jumping from one discrete atomic orbital
to another one
but the crucial thing here is
quantum mechanics isn't a theory of
pixels or quanta or anything like that
right it's a theory of wave functions
that are perfectly smooth there's an
equation for them the Schrodinger
equation and when you solve the equation
just like there are different
frequencies or fundamental and then
overtones when you pluck a string on a
violin or a guitar there is a discrete
set of solutions to the equation that
you get for the electron in the atom
that's why you see the discreteness not
because it's built in into the theory
but because it comes out in the
particular Solutions
exactly the same thing is going on with
Quantum field Theory why do you see
particles there's no particle-ness in
the fundamental definition of the theory
it comes out because there are solutions
to the theory that come in discrete
buckets one that has no energy at all
and we call that the vacuum and there
are no particles then there's a set of
solutions that have a little bit of
energy and we call that a one particle
solution maybe the particle is
stationary so does as low as possible
energy maybe it's moving so it's a high
energy particle but that's one set of
solutions and there's another set which
is two particle Solutions and so forth
all of the talk we do about particle
physics and so forth is a language that
we use to describe the solutions to the
equations of quantum field Theory so the
underlying languages Fields what you see
when you observe them are particles
and there's one more thing I want to say
about Quantum field theory that is going
to be crucially important for our story
which is the idea of effective field
Theory this came much later in the 60s
and 70s from Ken Wilson and other people
and the idea is the following that as it
was understood back in the 30s and 40s
if you just do Quantum field Theory
let's say Quantum electrodynamics right
QED so that's a theory that has
electrons and positrons and photons or
more accurately it has the fields
underlying them so it has the
electromagnetic field the electron field
the positron field and QED Quantum
electrodynamics the theory of their
interactions and people very quickly
wrote down with a guest such a theory
would look like and they very quickly
ran into trouble you could do an
approximation to what the theory was
telling you and it seemed to be kind of
like the right answer but then you go
beyond that approximation and you get
infinity you get an integral and you do
the integral and the answer is
infinitely big and that sounded bad
so people like Feynman and tamanaga and
schwinger and Dyson in the 1940s and 50s
figured out how to renormalize the
quantum field Theory and this was
something which in my personal opinion
was always presented as more weird and
mysterious than it should be to me it's
just a particular way of taking a limit
which is a very standard calculus based
move if you do things naively you get
infinity what you really want to do is
subtract Infinity from infinity and get
a finite answer
now that's by itself if you just say do
that say here's an Infinity here's
another Infinities subtract them tell me
the finite answer that's an ill-defined
problem you can't do that but under
certain specific physical conditions
when you have a well-defined idea of
what it is you're after you can turn it
into a well-defined problem you can take
the limit as one quantity is getting
bigger and bigger and there's another
quantity that's getting bigger and
bigger and you let them go to Infinity
individually but subtract them off and
get a finite answer at the end of the
day so I was never worried about
renormalization as an idea but
nevertheless
it was a hint that there was something
maybe sketchy going on at the
foundations of quantum field Theory and
so Ken Wilson in the 1960s if you think
about that moment in history it was just
the beginning of people trying to do
slightly larger scale computer work than
they had done before you know there were
computers but they were used for pretty
simple things the idea of simulating a
Quantum field theory on a computer was
not well established at all and that was
one of Wilson's projects he started
thinking about this and what he realized
is you know you can just do this most
straightforward thing all you take all
of space time and you discretize it so
you say rather than there being a smooth
space time underneath my feet I'm going
to take a lattice a series of dots with
a certain distance between them and I'm
going to approximate my Quantum field
Theory by doing some finite difference
method mathematical manipulations rather
than a smooth differential equation kind
of thing that the theory itself tells
you to do so this wasn't supposed to be
replacement it's just a calculational
tool you can do what is called lattice
Quantum field Theory as an approximation
and then you sort of do it for different
sizes of the lattice and then you take
the limit as the lattice size gets
arbitrarily small goes to zero and then
presumably you recover the smoothness of
the original Theory
what Wilson realized is that when you do
this when you do the first step in
putting the theory on a lattice all the
Infinities disappear
right away the reason why there ever
were Infinities you can think about in
terms of Feynman diagrams right Feynman
one of the things he did was figure out
a way to calculate scattering processes
in Quantum field Theory by writing down
these little cartoon pictures of
particles bumping into each other
and one of the features of flemen
diagrams is they help you see where the
Infinities might be lurking namely the
Infinities lurk in the loops in the
Feynman diagram you can imagine in your
head drawings were a different stick
figure Feynman diagrams for electrons
and positrons and photons bumping into
each other and scattering and going off
their separate ways the simplest
diagrams will be what are called tree
diagrams they just have some lines and
you cannot with your finger trace a
closed loop in any of those lines it
looks more like a tree okay but then
there are more complicated diagrams more
topologically involved ones where
somewhere in the middle of the diagram
there is a loop that you can go around
with your finger forever and ever if you
wanted to and the rules that Feynman
wrote down say that what the diagrams
are are ways of representing individual
numerical contributions to the final
answer that you're trying to get what is
the probability that this electron is
going to scatter off of that positron
for example
and so when you have a loop
you go through the math what do you
figure out when you ask the question
well okay how much energy or how much
momentum does this particular particle
in the loop have the answer is it is not
constrained
you can have an infinite series an
infinite sequence of different possible
momenta that any one particle in the
loop can have as long as you correctly
balance it against all the other
particles in the loop at every vertex in
the diagram energy is conserved but we
think about a certain undefined or
unconstrained momentum flowing around
the loop literally called The Loop
momentum it's not very clever
and what Wilson realized they people
knew this but he sort of appreciated the
implications of it is that the reason
why you had Infinities in the first
place is because you were considering
momenta in the loop of your Feynman
diagrams that were arbitrarily large you
took the momentum from zero to infinity
and you added them all together
and in Quantum field Theory or in
quantum mechanics more generally High
momentum and high energy correspond to
short distances right basically because
everything is a wave at the end of the
day and high energy waves are those with
short wavelengths so high energy waves
are those that can probe short distances
and so when Wilson tried to put his
Quantum field theory on the lattice in
order to do a computer simulation all
the Infinities went away because he was
not including arbitrarily short
distances he had gotten rid of those
arbitrarily short distances by putting
the theory on a lattice and yeah you or
I would say okay that's that was good
for our computer simulation so be it
what makes people Geniuses is they can
see the implications of these things
that are put in front of their noses and
Wilson said well
why was I ever of the opinion that I
knew what was happening at arbitrarily
short distances anyway
what right do I have to say that I
understand physics
as length scales go to zero I mean after
all I don't know whether he said this
out loud but certainly this is something
we would say today there's something
called the Planck scale right the length
scale I I never remember what it is 10
to the minus 35 centimeters or something
the length scale that seems to be the
length scale at which quantum gravity
becomes important maybe space time
itself is not really well defined on
those scales so I don't know what's
going on I don't know what new particles
are there there could be very very heavy
particles a heavy particle is a so a
massive particle has a lot of energy
because it equals m c squared so the
wavelength associated with a very
massive particle is very short so maybe
there are virtual very high mass
particles that I don't know about that
could change things and the Brilliance
of Wilson was to realize it didn't
matter
what happened at the very short
distances at the very high energies that
is both where the Infinities were
lurking but also a place where we have
no right to say we know what's going on
so Wilson says let's be honest
let's ask whether we can do physics at
low energies and long wavelengths
without specifying what happens at high
energies and you know maybe in some
other possible world the answer could
have been you can't you need to know
what's going on in short distances to
know what's going on at long distances
but in our world that turns out not to
be the case
so Wilson says let's just be explicit
let's be honest let's say we have what
we now call an UltraViolet cut off
we have an energy above which we have no
idea what's going on
below which we're going to try to have a
theory that describes what is going on
so the ultraviolet cutoff separates the
energy scales or the length scales that
we do claim to understand low energies
long wavelengths from those that we
don't claim to understand short
distances short wavelengths High
energies and Wilson showed that this was
sort of in keeping with the whole idea
of renormalization because you might say
all right if I ignore what's going on at
high energies well I could get in
trouble because things could happen at
high energies that might be important
but Wilson was able to show that yeah
things can happen
but all that they do as far as the low
energy
Dynamics is concerned is give you
certain definite numbers for what the
low energy equations of motion look like
so the mass of a particle the coupling
constants like the fine structure
constant or the strong interaction find
structure constant the expectation value
of the Higgs bows on all these different
parameters of particle physics
they do depend on your ultraviolet cut
off but there's no extra information
that comes in or at least there's a
little bit of extra information but it
also can be absorbed into what we call
irrelevant operators there's a whole
song and dance this is the whole story
which is long and involved and beautiful
of effective field Theory the idea of
infected field theory is
you can do Quantum field Theory
perfectly well
at energies below the ultraviolet cut
off without knowing what the physics is
above the ultraviolet cut off even if
space and time themselves exist above
the ultraviolet cut off you don't need
to know that it will not show up in your
low energy effective Quantum field
Theory so this and other things are not
exactly this but you know related things
one Wilson the Nobel Prize and the
undying reverence of modern Quantum
field theorists by the way if you're
interested knowing why I'm so hyped up
on this this will be a big part of
volume 2 of the biggest ideas in the
universe remember the my book series
volume 1 space time in motion is all
about classical physics including
relativity Volume 2 will be quanta and
Fields so I do a little bit of quantum
mechanics but mostly it's Quantum field
Theory and particle physics and I place
a huge amount of emphasis on effective
field Theory vitamin diagrams and
renormalization so remember the spirit
of the book is I give you a little bit
of the equations so you can actually see
them in action and you can see what it
means to say there's an UltraViolet cut
off the Dynamics don't depend on it
there is are we normalization that uh
will tell you how to change your
parameters so that the physics is
independent of the value of the
ultraviolet cut off Etc sadly the book's
not going to be out until early next
year but keep your calendars ready for
2024 when the biggest ideas Volume 2
comes out all of this will become much
clearer
okay
this is what we call a good news bad
news situation in the game okay because
what's the good news the good news is
that effective field theories are
effective in some sense we were already
using that fact before we knew it you
know the first field Theory the first
modern Quantum field theory is written
down by Enrico Fermi in his theory of
beta Decay and the fields that he was
considering were protons and neutrons
and electrons and neutrinos
these days we know number one that
protons and neutrons are not Elementary
Fields you can still treat them as
fields and the particles as vibrations
in the fields but we have a deeper
picture in which they are quarks and
gluons and so forth and also we know
that the beta Decay interaction is an
example of the weak interactions
mediated by W bosons Fermi didn't know
any of that why was Fermi in the 1930s
able to invent such a good Theory
without knowing about quarks and gluons
and the W bosons the answer is that
secretly he has an effective field
Theory his theory is valid below a
certain energy scale thing about
effective field theories is they will be
valid below the ultraviolet cutoff they
may or may not continue to be valid
above the ultraviolet cutoff when you go
above the ultraviolet cutoff you are
open to the possibility that very new
physical phenomena kick in maybe new
particles new Fields maybe even
something that is not in the realm of
quantum field Theory at all that's the
power of effective field Theory it
doesn't need to assume that the
fundamental nature of reality is a
Quantum field Theory the low energy
visible nature of reality will still be
very well
described by a Quantum field Theory even
if it's strings or Loops or triangles or
whatever at the deepest level
Quantum field Theory at the effective
level will be valid below the
ultraviolet cut off and that's exactly
what Fermi had stumbled upon his theory
is valid up until you get to the scale
of the W boson which is 80 billion
electron volts which is way higher than
they had access to in the 1930s
that's the good news
the bad news is the same news the same
phenomenon that makes effective field
theories so effective at low energies
and they're the theories that you know
we test at the Large Hadron Collider Etc
makes our questions about what goes on
past the ultraviolet cut off very very
difficult to answer
Because unless you literally build a
particle accelerator and smash particles
together at Energy's scattering energies
higher than the ultraviolet cut off your
effective field theory is going to give
you whatever answer you want it's going
to be sorry it's gonna give you the
answer you need it's going to give you
the correct answer okay so there's a
phenomenon called decoupling
you can very easily imagine that there
are high energy processes heavy
particles new symmetries new forces
discreets based on whatever you want
above the high energy ultraviolet cut
off and you can't tell
you can't distinguish between any of
those possibilities just by doing
experiments at lower energies and by
lower energies we mean lower than the
highest energy experiments we've done
you know several trillion electron volts
now the Large Hadron Collider
so effective field theories are great
because they help us describe the world
very very accurately they sadly indicate
why it is hard to move beyond our
current best understanding because
indirect evidence is very very
Limited in what it can possibly tell us
and direct evidence is very expensive to
get you have to build a giant particle
accelerator anyway
that's a very important part of our
story because that's an important part
of why physics right now is having
trouble making wonderful fast dramatic
leaps in progress in fundamental physics
because effective field theories are
making it too accurate to describe the
world right now at the energies that we
have access to
okay let me Zoom through the rest of the
story I wanted to tell you about
um contemporary physics so it's not just
Quantum field Theory that's obviously
the centerpiece of everything but it
there are particular kinds of quantum
field theories Quantum field Theory as
we see it uh manifest in nature does
have that Pleasant property that
sometimes shows up that if it's allowed
to happen it seems to happen the
standard model of particle physics seems
to do everything possible that we can
think of a theory to do maybe other than
super symmetry which is a separate
question we'll get to later but the
first step is gauge invariance okay you
may have heard that the standard model
of particle physics is based on this
idea of gauge invariance gauge Symmetry
and it goes all the way back to
electromagnetism to Maxwell really but
let me say what gauge invariance is in a
more modern language in a field Theory
language right we have an electron and a
positron so these are charged particles
but they both have their fields that
there really vibrations in so there are
these fields filling all of space the
electron field the positron field and
modern Quantum field Theory you'd
actually join them together you would
join particles and anti-particles
together into a single mathematical
structure but that's okay you don't
doesn't matter conceptually there's an
electron field and a positron field
and it turns out
that these fields are complex Fields
what does that mean a field is just at
every number at every point in space
there's a number of value for the field
or maybe some slightly more
sophisticated geometric quantity so like
the electric field is a little Vector at
every point in space a vector has both a
magnitude and a Direction
the electron repositron fields and I'm
also ignoring spin because there's too
many things you've got to ignore but
that's okay at every point in space
there's a complex number that's what it
means to say they are complex Fields so
complex number is just not a complicated
number it's just a real number plus an
imaginary number A Plus IB okay where a
is a real number b is another real
number I is the square root of minus one
the imaginary unit so the numerical
value of the electron field at any one
point in space is a complex number A
Plus IB for some definite numbers A and
B
now one of the things about
this complex number set of complex
numbers is you can think of it as a
plane right we talk about the complex
plane it's almost like it is in fact a
two-dimensional Vector space you can
think about one axis being the real part
of the number which we've labeled a and
then the perpendicular axis is the
imaginary part of that complex number
which we've labeled B so you have a plus
IB a is going horizontally B is going
vertically the actual complex number A
Plus IB is some dot on that plane and
you can imagine drawing a line from the
origin to the dot which looks like a
little vector
the reason why I'm saying all that is
because if you've played around with
vectors ever in your life you might be
familiar with the idea that very often
the vector itself has some intrinsic
meaning but the particular coordinates
in which we express the vector don't
have any real physical meaning so if I
set a court set up a coordinate system
here in my room X Y and Z so maybe X is
going I'm pointing in a direction right
now you can't see me but that's X here's
Y and Z is vertical okay then I can tell
you what the components are of let's say
the electric field at one point in space
because it will have a component in the
X Direction a component in the y
direction a component of the Z Direction
but physically the electric field
doesn't know what components I've set up
it doesn't care the physics of the
electric field are independent of the
axes I use to define the components of
the field is the vector that matters not
the axes with which I Define it
so in some cases that will also be true
for complex numbers you have a plus IB
but you could rotate those two axes the
real axis what you're calling the real
axis and the imaginary axis you could
just rotate them and the physical
essence of the thing you're describing
is unaffected just like the physical
essence of the electric field is
unaffected by me changing coordinates
here in the room okay so if you have a
field that has that kind of invariance
that it is a complex number but it
doesn't matter how we choose to find
what is the real part and what is the
imaginary part as long as we do so
consistently
then you have a symmetry that kind of
invariance is called a symmetry and that
is the kind of thing that pervades all
of modern physics
and that might make sense see that that
kind of makes sense that it doesn't
really matter which is the real bar
which is the imaginary part that's a
human convention Okay blah blah and
that's fine
but what's going on in modern particle
physics is a little more subtle than
that it says that I'm picking at a point
right in front of my nose right now
again you can't see it but imagine a
point in space
it says at that point in space there's a
symmetry that says I can separately
rotate the real and imaginary part of
the electric field no physical
differences being made but I can pick a
different point any different point I
want it picks a point in your brain look
at that point and I can again rotate the
real imaginary part of the electric
field of these sorry the electron field
I can rotate the A and B components
together in some different coordinate
systems some different bases for the
vector space and the magical thing the
important thing is I can do that
separately at each point at every point
in space I can separately rotate the
real part in the imaginary part of the
electron field and this turns out to be
a symmetry of the theory okay that's a
gauge invariance it's the idea that you
can separately rotate the bases of your
vector space whatever that happens to be
at every point in space and the theory
as a whole is physically unaffected by
it another famous divot example are the
quarks you may have heard that quarks
come in colors they're either red green
or blue not real colors just Whimsical
names of particle physicists have given
to them it's not really even true that
quarks are red green or blue what really
is true is that there is a
three-dimensional Vector space and every
individual Quark field is has a certain
direction in that Vector space and the
basis the axes of the vector space are
the red Direction the blue Direction and
The Green Direction and guess what
nobody cares there's no physical
relevance to how you Orient your red
green and blue axes at every point in
space and you can rotate them
independently all throughout space time
that is a different kind of gauge
invariance so for the electron you were
just taking one direction of rotation
and that is called you one for the
quarks you have three different axes and
the rotations you do are called Su 3
that 1 and that three are literally the
number of Dimensions you're rotating
into each other uh in a weird counting
system because the complex plane counts
as one complex number so you're really
rotating one number into itself that's a
little bit of math you don't need to
worry about right now the point is
even though you might say very
reasonably that I don't care how I set
up a plus I B at any one point or red
green and blue at any one point I do
care physically how to relate them at
different points in space how do I know
if the electron field at this point and
the electron field at that point are
pointing in the same direction
if I've changed my axes a plus IB right
then I need to compare them somehow so
what I really need to do is a way to
take the electron field at one point in
space and walk it over to the other
point so that I can compare them you
can't just compare them at different
points they're not next to each other
you can subtract them from each other
they need to be next door so you need to
move the field at one point to the field
at another Point how do you do that
the answer which is you know the kind of
thing that makes graduate students in
physics just their eyes light up with
sparkles when they finally realize this
because it's very very beautiful and and
very very compelling
the idea the answer is you need another
field
you need a different field in addition
to the electron field itself you need a
field that tells you how to move the
value of the electron field at one point
to another point in space or the three
dimensions of the Quark color space to
another point in space or in real space
time
you have curvature right how can you
describe the value of a vector at one
point in space compared to the value at
another point you need to carry it and
you need a field to tell you how to
carry it
and these fields are called connection
fields for obvious reasons they help you
connect one point to another they are
also called gauge fields and in the case
of electromagnetism this gauge field is
literally the electromagnetic field what
do you think of as the electric field in
the magnetic field are the amount of
rate of change either in space or in
time of the underlying gauge field
in the case of quantum chromodynamics
and su3 they are the gluon fields in the
case of curved space time it is the
gravitational field there's a more
subtle connection there because there's
a metric and a connection but it's
another story that for another time the
point is that over and over again what
you see once you have a field theory is
the possibility of these gauge
symmetries which require a gauge field
to make mathematical sense of and that
field has a dynamics of its own you
don't need an electron field to run
around to have an electric field or
magnetic field likewise you don't need a
glue on field around sorry you don't
need a quart field around to have a glue
on field they have a life of their own
with their separate Dynamics
Maxwell when he wrote down Maxwell's
equations in the mid 19th century some
people will some people today will say
you know Maxwell he had the electric
field he had the magnetic field he
didn't know that there was gauge
invariance that there was a
electromagnetic potential field from
which you could make that
um he did he totally knew that if you
look at Maxwell's books he absolutely
knew that you could construct
um what we now call the gauge field for
electromagnetism and from them by taking
derivatives of them make the electric
field of the magnetic field what he
didn't have was the whole symmetry group
idea he didn't have the idea that the
matter Fields like the electron would
also be Fields with their own ways of
changing under these gauge symmetries
but he knew about gauge invariance and
classically Maxwell's electrodynamics is
like the
Paradigm of a wonderful classical field
Theory and it was soon developed into
the Paradigm of a wonderful Quantum
field Theory Quantum electrodynamics QED
was the first Quantum field Theory to be
really really studied in detail and
phenomologically successful
so people knew about gauge invariants
and they knew that it was wonderful and
it was a very very natural thing to say
well maybe the forces that we don't
understand so thinking now the 1950s
okay we've done pretty well with QED and
electromagnetism but like I said we had
these things called nuclei where the
protons and neutrons are hanging out
together and there must be a force
holding them together because the
electromagnetic force all by itself
would push protons apart it would not
hold them together so we need a new
Force maybe people said it's a force
that is kind of like electromagnetism
but more complicated and the first
people to say this were Yang and Mills
and so they invented yangmil's theories
but there's an instantly a problem with
yangmil's Theory so Yang Mills theories
are theories with connections with Gauge
invariants but in a more complicated way
uh the technical terms are non-abelian
the Symmetry group does not commute with
itself it matters which symmetry
transformation you do first and then
second versus second then first who
cares we don't care about that that's
not our goal right now the point is
there was a generalization of the idea
of gauge invariance that seemed maybe
promising but had a huge problem right
from the bat namely that the photon
the particle that carries
electromagnetic force the particle
excitation of the underlying gauge field
in electromagnetism is massless
it moves at the speed of light it zooms
across space very easily very readily
okay it gives rise to a long range Force
Coulomb's law is just like Newton's law
of gravitation it's an inverse Square
law it is very easy to extend the
electromagnetic force across great
distances in space this turns out not to
be
a weird quirky thing this turns out to
be apparently a necessary feature of
gauge theories the field that is the
connection that you get when you have a
gauge Theory
seems from the math to be necessarily
massless and massless particles are easy
to make and easy to see but the 1950s
they didn't see any massless particles
popping out of the nucleus so what's
going on with that okay you might think
I've been going on too long I have but
I'm going to make it a little bit
shorter now so I'm going to really sort
of shortcut how to get out of this
problem but I really want to highlight
the problem of the massless gauge bosons
because it really bug people for decades
and
there's two forces that you might worry
about the weak nuclear force and the
strong nuclear force and because nature
wants to make life as hard as possible
for graduate students in physics it
solves the problem in two totally
different ways for the weak nuclear
force and the strong nuclear force for
the strong nuclear force it solves the
problem because the gluons which are the
gauge bosons of the strong force
interact with each other
and they interact with each other very
strongly so strongly that even though
they are massless and they do want to
move at the speed of light in fact they
are confined inside strongly interacting
particles like protons and neutrons and
mesons and so forth so that's a very
interesting piece of quantum field
Theory uh won the Nobel Prize for David
Pulitzer and David Gross and Frank
wilchak under the name of asymptotic
freedom but the basic lesson is the
quarks are mass the the gluons rather
are massless but you can't see them
because they're confined inside
collections of strongly interacting
particles
in the weak interactions the answer is
the Higgs mechanism this is why the
Higgs boson was such a big deal uh the
first person to actually point out what
was going on was Philip Anderson who was
better physicist who passed away uh he
won the Nobel Prize separately for his
work in condensed batter physics but the
idea is spontaneous symmetry breaking
if you have another feel that is
invariant under this cage invariance
that you've invented but it gets a
non-zero value in empty space a vacuum
expectation value that will give you the
impression that apparently the Symmetry
is being broken
and that will allow the bosons the gauge
bosons that were supposed to be massless
to now be massive which we know the w
and z bosons actually are this is what
actually happens
but the first investigations of the
spontaneous imagery breaking by people
like nambu and Goldstone and others saw
that even though you could give a mass
to
sorry they sorry they didn't say that
they were worried let me get it exactly
right they were worried about global
symmetries not gauge symmetry so there's
no gauge bosons at all you could only do
that rotation uniformly throughout space
when you rotate the different axes
together okay
in these Global symmetries there's a
theorem goldstone's theorem that says
you will always get a different kind of
massless boson basically because it
causes Zero Energy to move around this
field that you have used to uh that gets
it on zero value in empty space and
again you don't see any of these
massless bosons so people were you know
kind of grumbling and like well it's a
mathematically cute idea doesn't seem to
work it was Anderson who pointed out
that the two problems cancel each other
out
that if you have spontaneous symmetry
breaking with a gauge symmetry rather
than a global symmetry then the would-be
Goldstone bosons the particles that were
supposed to be new massless bosons when
you broke the Symmetry get eaten
by the Gage bosons and the Gage bosons
by doing that get heavy
so rather than getting two kinds of
massless bosons massless cage bosons
carrying the force and the massless
Goldstone bosons from breaking the
Symmetry you get one kind of massive
bosons and that's exactly the scheme
that was used in what we now call the
electro weak Theory so Higgs and even
before Higgs brow and on glare and just
after Higgs uh garalnik hogget and
kibble they followed Anderson and they
really did the particle physics of it
Anderson was still thinking like a
condensed matter person but Anderson was
trying to point out to his particle
physics Quantum field Theory friends
that they could escape this puzzle if
you spontaneously broke a gauge symmetry
there's no massless particles lying
around interesting side light look it's
my podcast I can ramble on as long as I
want interesting side light about this
we're going to get to the crisis in
physics soon don't worry
um why didn't Philip Anderson who's a
very smart guy push his idea harder you
know in the history of physics you get
credit for coming up with ideas but you
also get credit for sort of believing
your own ideas and pushing them and
Anderson didn't really quite follow
through on his idea that uh spontaneous
breaking of gauge symmetries gives you
no massless bosons at all and the answer
as far as I can tell is the cosmological
constant problem
this is worth talking about because it's
going to come up more than once
the cosmological constant problem is the
idea that ever since Einstein says that
general relativity is a theory of Curves
space-time
it was open to the possibility that
there is a vacuum energy
that there's an energy density in empty
space itself and this is mathematically
identical to Einstein's idea of the
cosmological constant they're the same
thing there's no difference there's not
like this is the cosmological constant
that's the vacuum energy they're the
same thing okay just different languages
used to describe the same idea the
difference is that you know long after
Einstein by the 50s and 60s people
realize there could be different
contributions to the cosmological
constant so in fact Feynman I think I
understand this correctly but you know
it's not a common fact so maybe I'm
hallucinating a little bit
one of feynman's motivations for
inventing Feynman diagrams was to get
rid of quantum field Theory you know
back in the 50s you could be ambitious
like that right now Quantum field Theory
works too well that's it's a harder
ambition to have but in the 1950s you
could have said well maybe I can get all
the benefit of quantum field Theory
without all the downside like the
Infinities right and one of the things
that he knew was a problem Feynman
was that if you have a field that fills
all of empty space even if there's no
particles right even if it's in its
lowest energy state in the vacuum state
it can still have energy
it can have what we call the Zero Point
Energy and naively you calculate Zero
Point Energy and it's hugely big in fact
it's infinitely big but Feynman wasn't
surprised by that lots of things in
Quantum field Theory are infinite
so that's what we call the cosmological
constant problem naively in Quantum
field Theory there is a Quantum
contribution to the energy of the vacuum
which is very very big maybe infinitely
big depending on your attitude towards
High momentum high energy modes of the
quantum fields and Feynman thought that
maybe he could invent a theory that was
a truly particle theory right that was
really a theory of individual photons
and electrons and so forth that would
replace Quantum field Theory it didn't
work nowadays we know that what filament
diagrams really are are a useful
calculational tool for talking about
Quantum field Theory not a replacement
of quantum field Theory so if I mean was
motivated by the cosmological constant
problem but it ended up not being very
relevant to what he actually did
same thing is true for Phil Anderson and
spontaneous imagery breaking Anderson
realized that if there was a field
filling all of space
that was breaking these gauge symmetries
it would carry energy that field and he
estimated the size that it was big much
bigger than was possibly Allowed by
cosmological observations
so Anderson said yeah that's probably
not on the right track I will spend my
time doing other things
since then we have learned to mostly
ignore this problem now we don't ignore
the cosmological constant problem we
know it's a problem but we state that
it's a problem we state that it's
important to think about we try to think
about it except that when we're doing
Quantum field Theory we just say yeah
for some reason the vacuum energy is
very very small we don't know why but it
is that's the best we can do right now
for the cosmological constant problem
and again that's gonna it turns out that
in 1998 we discovered that the universe
is accelerating we had Adam Reese on the
podcast he was one of the discoverers of
that and that seems to be best fit by
the idea there is a tiny amount of
cosmological constant out there a tiny
amount of energy in the vacuum much much
smaller than you would estimate either
from the Zero Point Energy of the
quantum fields or the extra energy you
get from the Higgs field so there's
still a cosmological constant problem
but it's not why is the cause Marshall
constant zero it's why is it a small not
quite zero number that's the current
version of the cosmological constant
problem
okay so then there's a whole bunch of
more details
about uh parity violation and
non-performative phenomena and
confinement and gluons and generations
and families and all these things that
ultimately
Triumph in the 1970s in the standard
model of particle physics and as you
know sometimes I like to talk about the
core theory that was a name given by
Frank wilczak what's the difference
between the core Theory and the standard
model the standard model is everything
other than gravity
because we say oh yeah gravity has it
does not have a full Quantum field
Theory description or Quantum
description yet so it doesn't count
which is true that we do not have a full
quantum theory of gravity yet but
remember what I just told you a few
minutes ago about effective field
theories right if you confine your
attention
not to every possible situation but to
certain situations situations where the
fields are relatively low energy and
long wavelength then you can invent an
effective field theory that is true
below some ultraviolet cutoff so it
turns out you can a hundred percent do
that for Gravity no problem whatsoever
in including gravity in your effective
low energy Theory below the UV cut off
that you personally favor and that's
what the core theory is the core theory
is the effective field theory that
includes both the standard model and the
weak field limit of general relativity
so it doesn't include the Big Bang or
black holes but that's okay we don't
have the big bang or any black holes
here in the solar system as far as we
know so our lives are very well
described by the core Theory
again good news bad news situation an
amazing Triumph the core Theory the
standard model in the 1970s made
predictions right the w and z bosons
were predicted and then observed uh the
generation structures of the quarks and
the lepton so that when we discovered
the bottom Quark we knew there had to be
a top Quark we discovered that we
predicted the Higgs boson took a long
time to discover that comes around in
2012.
um that's good news there's nothing but
good news many Nobel prizes were given
out for all the work that went into
constructing this model the bad news is
several decades later that model
continues to fit the data
there were two tiny updates right around
the turn of the 21st century one is
neutrinos have mass that was not part of
the original standard model but everyone
knew it was not hard to put into the
standard model again it's sort of this
weak understanding situation where we
don't know exactly what the mechanism is
responsible for neutrino masses but it's
easy enough to include them so it's a
modification of the standard model but
not an overthrowing of it in any sense
the other one was of course the
discovery in 1998 of the acceleration of
the universe again put one number the
vacuum energy into the theory and there
you have it other than that the theory
we're using today is the same theory
that we had in the mid 1970s
other than the vacuum energy and the
neutrino masses
there have been no
surprising
experimental results in fundamental
physics since the 1970s by surprising I
mean something we didn't anticipate in
our favored theoretical models so
enormous credit to people who discovered
the Higgs boson or discovered
gravitational waves and so forth but
these were things that were predicted a
long time ago the Higgs boson comes from
the 1960s we were talking about
gravitational waves not long after
Einstein invented general relativity so
Tour de forces on the experimental side
and the vision that was required to
build the experiments and the
observatories that would find them and
then to do it correctly deserves all the
credit all the Nobel prizes I still
think someone on the experimental side
should win the Nobel Prize for
discovering the Higgs we all know that
the issue there is that the
collaborations that did it had thousands
of people on them and the rules the
self-imposed rules of the Nobel
committee are the no more than three
individuals can win the Nobel Prize in
physics at any one time I would still be
happy if someone like Lynn Evans who was
someone who saw the construction of the
LHC through through various little
crises uh might be a very good person to
win a Nobel Prize but they don't ask me
I'm not on on that particular committee
anyway so that's the weird situation
we're in so I hope you can now that's a
very long Exposition I hope it was
useful for some people out there but the
point for everybody is
we have a theory that does really well
and not only that we kind of know why it
does really well it's because of the
magic of effective field theories the
field theory that we now have if you
take a cut off that is up there you know
somewhere around the Large Hadron
Collider energy scale so some trillions
of electron volts we've looked below
that scale and we've seen a bunch of
particles and they're the particles that
we thought were going to be there back
in the 1970s we haven't seen anything
new and we don't need anything new to
fit the data so that's a weird situation
to be in I'm gonna be a little bit more
specific about it okay the the ways in
which we nevertheless try to get some
guidance as to where to go next but I
want to emphasize that it's a weird
situation to be in and it's not
because we're dumb it's not because
there's a conspiracy or a cabal to keep
the truth hidden or anything like that
it's because of how nature works it's
because physicists have been smart not
dumb they've been able to develop a
theory that is a completely effective
Quantum field Theory up to a very very
high energy scale and without building a
giant particle accelerator to go beyond
that energy scale we have to cross our
fingers and hope we get lucky if we want
to get experimental data to guide us in
the quest to go beyond that so it's not
like if people were just you know more
open-minded or smarter or more willing
to challenge the man then we could make
huge progress none of those attitudes
change the fact that we have a good
effective field theory that
that keeps the possible wild new physics
at higher energies and shorter distances
hidden from us in a very direct physical
way so whatever you may think about the
current state of physics you have to do
so from a perspective that appreciates
the
barriers and obstacles that are given to
us by Nature by the universe by the
World by physics not by human foibles
human foibles are out there and they're
they're adorable let me tell you but we
have to understand what they are and we
have to take into account the real
obstacles that no amount of uh human
thinking is going to let us run around
or wriggle out of okay
so with that all has very long prologue
let us consider what we're doing right
now in physics what are we trying to do
to get Beyond uh the standard model the
core Theory Etc because I guess the
other thing to say is the other slightly
weird thing is
it's not just
that we have a theory that fits all the
data because then you might just declare
Victory you think it's okay we're done
right that's not quite the situation
we're in we have a theory that fits all
the data and yet almost every working
physicist is convinced the theory is not
right
or at least that it's not complete okay
like just like Einstein was convinced
that quantum mechanics is not complete
and there's various reasons to think
that we're not done yet so we have a
theory that the data is not telling us
not giving us any clues how to move
Beyond but which we don't think is right
which we think is certainly part of some
bigger and better theory that we don't
have yet that's a very tough situation
to be in there's no direct experimental
guidance so why don't we think we're
right why don't we just declare Victory
why don't we just say that we're done
with fundamental physics and move on
well there's a number of different kinds
of things going on here one is very very
directly we have phenomena that we only
weakly understand in the classification
system I offered most importantly the
dark matter and the dark energy right
we have this pie chart of the
ingredients in the universe it's
possible I don't want to do my own horn
but we're like pass an hour into the
podcast now it's possible I was the
first person to make that pie chart of
the dark matter the dark energy and the
ordinary matter again zero IQ points are
required to do that first but I was just
you know in that discourse that was
going on when the dark energy was first
discovered and settled down I thought
that this is clearly an example of why a
place where a pie chart is the right way
to express what we now know and in fact
if you go to my website
preposterousuniverse.com there's a
little you know icon that you see in the
tabs telling you which web page you're
on and the icon on my website is that
little pie chart uh that's why it's
called Preposterous Universe because
it's a joke right the universe is not
Preposterous it just eludes our
understanding and the pie chart is five
percent of the known universe is
ordinary matter which I mean all of the
stuff in the standard model of particle
physics all the atoms all the particles
you've ever made in a lab five percent
of the universe 25 is dark matter which
is some kind of matter right some
particle-like thing in some way
um but is not something that any of the
particles in the standard model can be
we've ruled them out using various
techniques and the dark energy seventy
percent is smoothly distributed it's not
matter it does not evolve as matter it
does not uh Clump it does not move
around like matter does it's a good fit
to the data to say that it's perfectly
smooth just like the cosmological
constant
but in the case of both the dark matter
and the dark energy
we're not sure what they are so we have
models that fit the data but we don't
know which if any of those models is the
right one so let's let's think very
carefully about dark matter because it
gets a certain reputation that I think
you know you you want to think clearly
about the dark matter
so the first thing to realize about the
dark matter is it exists we we have
enough data enough information to say
that dark matter is real okay
that doesn't mean that gravity is not
also doing something weird in cosmology
so those of you I know that there's
probably a heterogeneous audience out
here some of you are hearing some of
these vocabulary words for the first
time others have been hearing far too
much about it
but there is the following very very
natural line of thought
how do we know there's Dark Matter well
you know we look at some astrophysical
thing like a Galaxy or a cluster of
galaxies we know how gravity works right
it's a fact of gravity
in the observable universe that actually
Newtonian gravity works pretty well you
know Newtonian gravity fails when
gravity becomes very very strong like
near a black hole or something like that
it also fails if you want to have a
source of gravity that is relativistic
like photons or whatever but in the
world around us if you stay away from
the black holes at centers of galaxies
for galaxies and for clusters and stuff
like that Newton's approximation works
very well for figuring out what the
gravitational field actually is and in
Newtonian gravity there's a very direct
correlation between how much stuff you
have how much matter you have and how
strong the gravitational field is so you
can implicitly work out for example the
mass of the Sun by just seeing how the
planets orbit around the sun figuring
out their gravitational force that makes
that happen and inferring the mass of
the sun
so you can also play that same game for
galaxies and clusters
and what you find is the gravitational
field necessary to account for the
Motions that you see in galaxies and
clusters is substantially larger
than the amount of stuff that you can
actually discern the amount of ordinary
matter
so you have to be careful about that I
mean obviously maybe you've just missed
some ordinary matter like maybe it's
invisible maybe it's just not glowing at
the wavelengths you like and in fact if
you just counted Stars you would be well
under counting the total mass of
galaxies and clusters most of the mass
in a cluster for example the ordinary
mass is in hot Intergalactic gas that is
uh turns out you can see it if you look
in the x-rays because it's hot so it's
giving off x-rays you can actually find
it nowadays but in the 1970s you
couldn't find it
so because the gravitational field is
larger than what you see and by the way
again I should I should be very very
clear because it is worth getting this
right we have separate completely
independent ways of figuring out how
much ordinary matter there is in the
universe
we had that both from the cosmic
microwave background which implicitly
has its patterns of temperature
fluctuations depend on the amount of
ordinary matter and also from primordial
nucleosynthesis the early Universe was a
nuclear reactor it was fusing protons
and neutrons into helium and lithium and
deuterium in a way that depends on how
much ordinary matter there is
so all of these lines of evidence direct
inventories the cosmic microwave
background Big Bang nucleosynthesis they
give us the same answer they all agree
five percent of the matter density of
the energy density in the universe is in
ordinary matter so the idea that there's
just more you know Brown dwarfs or
planets out there or so forth that's not
going to fly for the whole Dark Matter
issue so where is this extra gravity
coming from that we appear to get in
galaxies and clusters the obvious simple
answer is maybe there's more matter than
you see so it's not ordinary matter
maybe it's extraordinary matter which we
call Dark Matter something that has to
be a different kind of particle not in
the standard model but there's another
very obvious thing to think which is
that all of our reason for believing in
Dark Matter comes not from directly
detecting it not from putting our
fingers on it and touching it directly
but from seeing its gravitational
influence right
so of course it's possible that what
we're seeing is not that there's new
matter but that gravity is different on
these cosmological scales than it is
let's say here in the solar system a
theory of modified gravity that is one
hundred percent a sensible thing to
think about
so let me be very clear there's no sense
whatsoever in which the establishment is
keeping people from thinking about
modified Gravity used to everyone in the
establishment has thought about modified
gravity I've thought about it my most
highly cited paper is on the idea of
modified gravity but
nevertheless the data have spoken
gravity might very well be modified but
dark matter is still there so let me be
very clear about why that's true because
it's important for this and let me first
say before why the data had spoken
let's see what the theory has to say
right
we talked before about effective field
theories
um gravity is a field Theory gravity is
an effective field Theory the low energy
limit of general relativity is the Right
theory to use when describing these
galaxies and clusters and so forth and
Ken Wilson taught us how to think about
these effective field theories and part
of his
catechism is that it is Perfectly
Natural
for the field theory that you know and
love
to change and be modified at small
distances and high Energies
it is not at all natural for a Quantum
field Theory to change and be modified
at long distances and low energies it is
hard to hide new effects
that would be important at very very
large length scales and not at medium
like scales so it is very hard to come
up with new effects that will be
relevant for Galaxies but invisible in
the solar system
now just because it's hard it doesn't
mean you can't do it that's why people
try to do it that is why people like me
have written down theories and they go
to Great Lengths to say well okay why
haven't we actually seen these effects
here in the solar system Etc I'm just
trying to let you know
that in case you're saying well if we've
only tested general relativity really
well in like you know pulsars and the
solar system or whatever why shouldn't
it be different in galaxies and clusters
and there's an answer to that because
effective field Theory says it won't be
again it's easy to imagine changing it
in galaxies and clusters but very hard
to imagine ways of changing it that
don't show up in other experiments you
have to work to do that you can but you
have to work to do it so theoretically
it's already you know a few strikes
against the idea of modifying gravity
and then what about observationally well
here is the test when someone says I
want to modify gravity I think I can do
away with dark matter
and you say well how do you explain the
observational evidence for dark matter
if they start talking about galaxies and
spiral galaxies and rotation curves you
you can stop listening you know you
don't need to really take them seriously
because historically
the first evidence for Dark Matter came
from clusters and galaxies arguably it
came from clusters Fritz's Wiki as long
as the 1930s pointed out there needs to
be more matter but zwiki's observations
and and theories were not good enough to
say that you couldn't just have ordinary
matter you hadn't found yet it was
really Vera Rubin and Ken Ford with
their observations of spiral galaxies in
the 70s and so forth that really said
okay here is
force due to gravity that is not
accounted for by the ordinary matter and
so we need something new okay but now
that is no longer the best evidence for
dark matter it's true that historically
that was the first evidence but these
days we have way better evidence we have
evidence from large-scale structure and
how it evolved we have evidence from
gravitational lensing but mostly most
importantly we have evidence from the
cosmic microwave background those tiny
temperature fluctuations in the cosmic
microwave background evolve in a very
predictable way in a way that depends on
precisely how much dark matter versus
ordinary matter you have in the universe
it is really quantitatively beautiful
and precise it is quantitatively much
better evidence for the existence of
dark matter and for the properties of
Dark Matter than anything about clusters
and galaxies and as I'll explain in a
second it's really evidence for dark
matter not for modified gravity so if
someone says they can do away with dark
matter and replace it with modified
gravity they have to start by explaining
the cosmic microwave background they
should start by accounting for the best
evidence not for the oldest evidence
okay why is the cosmic microwave
background the best evidence
let's go back to the idea of Newtonian
gravity right I said the Newtonian
gravity was very straightforward it said
that the force due to gravity was
proportional to the amount of mass
causing the gravitational pull right and
that that's true but there's another
thing which is that the direction of the
gravitational force is pointing toward
where the mass is okay or if in a more
General circumstance when you have lots
of stars around you or whatever the net
gravitational
acceleration that you will feel in that
Newtonian limit is just the sum of the
individual accelerations from the stars
from the individual masses that are
causing the gravitational field so the
Newtonian gravity and which is the limit
though in the weak field of general
relativity is not just telling you the
strength of gravity but also the
direction in which it points
so how would you go about changing
gravity how do you go about modifying
gravity without any deep theoretical
superstructure just the idea of how
could gravity be modified
the easy thing to imagine doing and
certainly something that was at the top
of the minds of people who thought about
rotation curves and things like that
when they try to get rid of dark matter
back in the day is that you change the
inverse Square law
that is to say the inverse squared law
says the strength of the gravitational
force is proportional to one over the
distance squared between the two bodies
that are attracting each other the
inverse Square law right so as long as
you just imagine changing that so the
gravity falls off more slowly than one
over distance squared you might be able
to imagine coming up with a theory that
explains the spiral galaxy rotation
curves right
so but notice what you're doing you're
keeping the direction of the
gravitational force the same as Newton
had it all you're doing is changing the
magnitude of the gravitational force
from one over r squared to something
else and even if you don't have a
deep-seated Quantum field Theory
justification for doing so you can
imagine it you can imagine it fairly
straightforwardly on the basis of just
the phenomenology of gravity no one
would give you a hard time for letting
your imagination roam free there
but what if you wanted to change the
direction in which gravity pointed
that's much harder if you're if the gain
you're playing is
the source of gravity is just ordinary
matter there's no dark matter there's no
extra new sources of gravity there okay
and you're going to modify gravity but
the source of gravity is still ordinary
matter it's easy to imagine the strength
of gravity changing it's hard to imagine
the direction changing because how does
it change in what direction does it go
there's only one direction which is
toward the source but there's lots of
directions which are not toward the
source it's very hard to imagine just
changing the theory of gravity so that
the force of gravity points in a
different direction points somewhere
other than where the ordinary matter is
so if you go out and collect data
and the data are showing you not just
that the force of gravity declines under
a different pattern than one over r
squared but that the force of gravity
points in a different direction than
where the ordinary matter is that's
something that's going to be very hard
to explain by modifying gravity
guess what guess why I'm leading you
down this Primrose path because that is
exactly the data we have I mean maybe
the most aesthetically pleasing version
of it is something like the bullet
cluster the bullet cluster is this
example of two clusters of galaxies that
pass through each other
so that the hot dense Intergalactic
medium which is most of the ordinary
matter in the Clusters uh hit each other
created a shock wave and got stuck the
galaxies which are actually like tiny
little invisible things compared to the
giant Interstellar gas the galaxies just
pass right through each other right but
the galaxies are also tinier they they
don't weigh as much as The Intergalactic
gas
so in something like the bullet cluster
what would you predict if you asked the
question where is the gravity
if you modified gravity but didn't
believe in Dark Matter the answer you
would give is the gravity should Point
toward that Intergalactic gas because
that's where most of the matter is
but then you do the experiment you
collect the data you do gravitational
lensing and other things and you show
that where the gravity is is where the
galaxies are
not where the two Globs of hot
Intergalactic matter that bumped into
each other are but where the galaxies
are that passed right through
and that sounds puzzling but then you
realize oh I know what's going on
there's Dark Matter the dark matter in
the Clusters didn't shock against the
dark matter and the other clusters
because dark matter is collisionless it
just keeps going right that's one of the
features that we've figured out about
how dark matter behaves it does not
shock or bump into itself it just keeps
going along its merry way so the
prediction of the Dark Matter model is
that the gravitational field should be
where the galaxies are
the prediction of the modified gravity
models of the gravitational field should
be where the gas is in between in the
bullet cluster and the data say the
gravitational field is where the
galaxies are or more more honestly the
gravitational field is where the dark
matter is
now I say that's the most aesthetically
pleasing one because you can make these
beautiful pictures
and it's it's kind of vivid it's
visceral like you feel it in your bones
like oh yes there's like a picture of
where the dark matter is I get it but
there's clusters of galaxies they're
messy right I mean it's the same reason
why I'm saying don't worry about people
who put all the emphasis on individual
galaxies and clusters when they talk
about replacing the Dark Matter galaxies
are messy places clusters of galaxies
are messy places there's a lot of
astrophysics going on you might think
that despite everything there was some
weird unknown phenomenon going on as in
contrast we have the cosmic microwave
background the cosmic microwave
background we know what's going on and
the reason why is because there's only a
little tiny bit going on
the variation in temperature from point
to point in the cosmic Bikeway
background is one part in 10 to the five
right tiny little difference in
temperature from one point to another
and that makes it very easy to calculate
you're not calculating these giant
non-linear feedback mechanisms you're
calculating tiny variations on top of a
smooth background and so here's what
happens
and I've told this story elsewhere so I
do apologize if you've heard it before
but it for these purposes is super worth
it and the purposes remember are
explaining why we know Dark Matter
exists
so in the early Universe there are
deviations in density from place to
place maybe they came from inflation
maybe they came from somewhere else but
somewhere early in the universe we don't
know that's part of what we don't yet
understand no understanding I would say
but there's some initial condition and
then you can just say once you get the
initial condition what happens to it and
what happens is a region of the early
universe that is slightly over dense
will start to contract gravity turns up
the contrast knob on the universe over
dense regions become more over dense
under dense regions empty out
but this happens you know it can't
happen on a scale larger than the Hubble
radius The Horizon size at that time in
the early universe so basically as the
universe expands and slows down larger
and larger regions are able to collapse
are able to come together and coalesce
under their own gravitational pull
and so you see this Cascade of different
length scales on which these Dynamics
are taking place the smallest length
scales come first and they can you know
early on start this coalescence the
larger length scales will only happen
later
but at the in the early Universe it's
you know a hot plasma right this is
we're thinking now not the first
fraction of a second but we're thinking
the first hundred thousand years
it's still too hot for there to be atoms
there's electrons there's protons
there's photons Etc so when that
coalescence happens you not only
increase the density of matter in a
certain region you increase the
temperature it gets hotter it's like
pushing a piston together and what the
higher temperature means that there's a
pressure there's a restoring Force so
literally it bounces this region that
was initially over dense starts to
contract but it heats up pressurizes and
then pushes backward it starts to go the
other way it actually becomes under
dense compared to the surrounding medium
if this sounds a little bit like a sound
wave in the air you are exactly right
this is an acoustic wave in the early
universe so an initial overdense region
coalesces a little bit becomes a little
more over dense but then it quickly
bounces becomes under dense and then
it'll collapse again you know that
bounces back and forth It's oscillating
until the point where you hit
recombination where the electrons and
the protons come together to make atoms
now the universe is transparent and
things just collapse but before that
moment things were bouncing back and
forth
while this is happening okay so you have
small scales which will bounce back and
forth several times before recombination
larger scales which will bounce one or
two or three times before recombination
there's one more important effect going
on which is damping this is damping it
was first studied by Joe selk our recent
podcast guest in fact is called Silk
damping there's different kinds of
damping but the one of the more
important ones is silk damping and the
idea is that sure in one region you're
gonna coalesce collapse a little bit
heat up then you're going to expand
you're going to bounce back and forth
but all along you have photons passing
through the regions right photons moving
the speed of light and the photons in
some sense want to smooth things out in
the regions where you're over dense and
hotter there are more photons higher
energy they escape to the outside which
is less dense lower temperature and so
the photons damp the oscillations if you
had this ringing it is very much like
the ringing of a bell in the real world
it rings but eventually dies down
so those fluctuations those oscillations
those sound waves in the early Universe
on small scales will be damped compared
to the larger scales I'm going through
all the story because this story leads
to a prediction that leads to a
prediction for what you should see when
you look at how much variation there is
in temperature in the microwave
background namely when you look at small
scales there should be a little bit of
variation when you look at larger scales
up to about one degree on the sky there
should be more variation so you see this
if you've ever seen this famous plot
that came out of you know wmap or Planck
Etc there is the amount of temperature
variation as a function of angular scale
and they plot it so that large angles
are on the left small angles are on the
right and what you see is the there's a
curve that it goes up to a big peak then
it goes down and it goes up again to a
smaller Peak and then down smaller Peak
smaller Peak smaller Peak
if that were the whole story
if you had nothing but ordinary physics
no dark matter
bouncing back and forth because of these
thermal heating up stories you make a
very clear prediction that you and I can
understand even without running a
computer simulation right and the
prediction is
that the smaller scale fluctuations are
more damped than the larger scale ones
like we just said therefore in all of
these oscillations these Peaks that you
see in the power Spectrum as we call it
of the cosmic microwave background
there's the big first Peak at one degree
and then every Peak at smaller scales
should be consecutively smaller
but that's not what we see that's not
actually what the data say when you look
at the data what you see is that even
though there's one big first Peak
the second and third Peak are about the
same size
the third Peak is not suppressed with
respect to the second Peak they're about
the same and then the fourth and fifth
Peaks are both suppressed compared to
the second and third
it's almost as if
the odd-numbered Peaks are somehow being
boosted or the even numbered beaks are
somehow suppressed compared to what you
might naively expect
what is going on oh yes I know what's
going on dark matter
because dark matter doesn't participate
in this bouncing process the Dark Matter
again is collisionless it's dark it
doesn't interact with photons or the
bath or anything like that but we do
think again both theoretically and
confirmed by observation that those
initial perturbations and the density of
ordinary matter and the initial
perturbations in the density of Dark
Matter were lined up with each other so
there's these are what are called
adiabatic fluctuations
so the places where there was slightly
more density of dark matter are the same
places where there's slightly more
density of ordinary matter
such a place begins to contract because
of gravity the ordinary matter heats up
pressurizes and bounces but the dark
matter just keeps Contracting
then the ordinary matter
has bounced so much that it is less
dense than the surrounding regions but
it's an oscillating wave so it starts to
contract again so those Peaks that we
see in the data from the cosmic
microwave background represent the
extremes of this bouncing Evolution the
highest density and then the lowest
density to the highest density is a peak
the under density is a peak the high
density again is a peak the lower
density again is a peak the odd numbered
Peaks and the even-numbered Peaks
actually are physically different
the odd-numbered Peaks are that first
evolution
to just the overdense region
in that case the ordinary matter and the
dark matter are in lockstep they are
both evolving in the same direction so
they reinforce each other
but then the ordinary matter bounces and
the second Peak is its underdance but
that is not reinforced by the dark
matter the dark matter is still overdone
so there's a slight cancellation
and then it bounces back again and
they're back in Phase the ordinary
matter in the dark matter and they
reinforce each other again the odd
numbered Peaks see a reinforcement
between ordinary matter and dark matter
the even-numbered Peaks see a slight
cancellation between ordinary matter and
dark matter so
if you believe in dark matter which many
people did before they actually saw any
of this you would make a prediction
ahead of time and it would be very clear
that you would not see a uniform damping
of all the peaks in the microwave
background what you would see is that
the even-numbered Peaks are more damped
compared to the odd-numbered Peaks and
that is exactly what is observed when
you actually collected the data this is
a prediction made ahead of time and the
Dark Matter prediction came out smack on
what you expect
can you do this with modified gravity
could you do this like you do the spiral
galaxies can you explain it away
well there's a slightly complicated
question here because what do you mean
by modified gravity how are you going to
actually modify gravity right like in
the Galaxy if you just change the one
over r squared law the inverse squared
law to something more
mild as you get to larger distances okay
you can imagine doing that just by
writing down some equation out of your
head but now with the bouncing of of the
early universe and the radiation matters
and the plasma and the Internet it's
kind of a little bit more complicated so
at first in the the historical
development of this controversy the
modified gravity people said well we
just don't know we're not exactly sure
what to predict
there was one issue which is that you
know the modified gravity people there's
a community in the 80s and 90s and they
just had these phenomenological rules
they didn't have a deep down theory that
was compatible with relativity and so
forth finally Jacob beckenstein came up
with such a theory a fully relativistic
model that would reproduce uh what is
known as mon uh this came from uh
Milgram modified Newtonian Dynamics it
was the first idea of fitting rotation
curves of galaxies by modifying gravity
and with Jacob beckenstein did was
basically put forward a fully blown
complete relativistic theory that
predicted the same predictions that
Monde would predict in fact I've heard
the following anecdote I'm not sure if
it's true or not but it it's amusing so
I'm going to choose to believe that it's
true
um before beckenstein wrote down his
theory
there was a story going around in the
anti-modified gravity or anti-mond
community
which said that uh you can't write down
a fully relativistic theory that gives
rise to Mond and they called it
beckenstein's theorem and it was just a
joke because the theorem was based on
the idea that Jacob beckenstein had
tried to write down such a theory and he
had failed and Jacob beckenstein is a
very smart guy so if he can't do it it
can't be done
but beckenstein heard about this and he
said I never tried to do that and then
he did try to do it and he succeeded
because he's a very smart guy
so this this theory in beckenstein's
original form was called Tevis uh tensor
Vector scalar theory if you look at it
oh my God it is the ugliest Theory
you've ever seen because again back
inside is a smart guy and there's an
enormous amount of constraints and
restrictions that you need to have to
fit all the data as well as to be
theoretically respectable not even clear
that it was 100 theoretically
respectable but was apparently a theory
that gave rise to the Monde
phenomenology and this happened before
we actually collected the data on the
cosmic microwave background so now you
have a theory that you can use to make a
prediction and people did it was a
heroic effort because it's not easy to
do this they made the predictions and
guess what you predicted a difference
between the modified gravity Theory and
the Dark Matter Theory you would not get
there's no reason in modified gravity to
get this difference between even
numbered Peaks and odd numbered Peaks
and so they didn't they got a smooth
decline in the Peaks
and they made a very explicit plot of
what they predicted that the CMB would
eventually look like it did not look
like that the data came in and they were
very clear that this particular
prediction prediction was wrong
physicists are stubborn and smart and
clever they don't give up so easily so
is it possible to come up with a theory
that is modified gravity in some sense
and correctly fits the cosmic microwave
background data if you are just
Shameless and and bend over backwards
and try to you know tweak your
parameters Etc yes it is possible to do
that now if that's true if it's possible
to come up with such a theory and fit
the microwave background which is the
best evidence we have for dark matter
why did I say earlier that we know that
dark matter exists because
you know you you've lost a little
sight of your original goal when you
started doing this when you look at
these theories even beckenstein's Theory
even the original Tevis model which was
supposed to reproduce the modified
gravity predictions why is it called
tepes
tensor Vector scalar while the tensor is
the good old gravitational field the
metric tensor that Einstein had but the
vector in the scalar referred to new
degrees of freedom new fields that
beckenstein had to put into his theory
and since then
every other person who has written down
versions of modified gravity uh that
claim to fit the CMB as well as other
things also adds a bunch of fields into
their theories how is it possible
to make a difference between the
even-numbered Peaks and the odd numbered
peaks in the CMB if the only
gravitational field is coming from
ordinary matter and the ordinary matter
is uniform in its stamping from high
from small scale from large scales to
small scales why would there be a
difference in the even numbered Peaks
and the odd numbered Peaks the answer
when you dig into it is that these other
fields that you invented to supposedly
modify gravity have energy
and they therefore create a
gravitational field and that
gravitational field is not coupled
directly to the ordinary matter it is
independent
in other words it is dark matter that is
what it is that's what dark matter is
dark matter is some new degree of
Freedom some new kind of field or
particle or whatever
that creates a gravitational field
other than the ordinary matter that we
know and love you if you want you can
just stamp your feet and say but I
choose to call this modified gravity not
dark matter
it's a free country be my guest but
you're not going to be able to explain
the cosmic microwave background without
new sources of gravity over and above
the ordinary matter that we know and
love because the ordinary matter
declines uniformly the data do not
in Dark Matter models this is obvious
and natural and immediate and very
pleasing in these other models you can
do it but all you've done is create a
really weird and Baroque and hard to
understand version of dark matter
now
having said all that let's be super
duper Fair here there's a reason why
people continue to pursue the idea of
modifying gravity because there's
something about the manifestation of
dark matter in galaxies and clusters
that is weird this is what Milgram first
seized on in the 1980s when he started
thinking about Bond there's a certain
phenomenology in the sense of a certain
way that we see things in the universe
that keep showing up
in galaxies and arguably in clusters
also but that's maybe a little bit
arguable but certainly in galaxies
there's a relationship between how the
ordinary matter behaves and how the Dark
Matter behaves and it's not immediately
explained by the Dark Matter hypothesis
whereas in modified gravity you can just
put it in as part of your modification
of gravity
um so this is what is called the Monde
phenomenology What bond what milgram's
theory modified gravity really does is
it predicts a certain feature of spiral
galaxies that is absolutely seen out
there in the universe and is not
directly predicted by the Dark Matter
Theory
so that motivates people to pursue this
dark matter idea but note the difference
here the problem with dark matter let's
put it this way the promise of modifying
gravity is that you can explain a
feature that is not yet otherwise
explained by the dominant Theory but the
problem with modified gravity is that it
doesn't fit the data it's ruled out
that's a bigger problem okay
it is important to try to understand why
dark matter and ordinary matter interact
the way that they do to give galaxies
certain structures this is absolutely a
perfectly legitimate thing to think
about and worry about and keep as a goal
in your mind
but it's also hard because like we said
at the start
galaxies are messy you know galaxies by
by construction or I shouldn't say by
construction but by observation what we
see is
in a spiral galaxy the centers of the
galaxies you don't really need Dark
Matter to explain what's going on it's
mostly ordinary matter that makes
perfect sense because ordinary matter
has dissipation it falls to the bottom
of a gravitational well much more
efficiently than dark matter does
and what Milgram points to in his
phenomenology is that there's a certain
radius in spiral galaxies inside of
which you don't need Dark Matter outside
of which you do so that's what he tries
to explain by modifying gravity
by all means
have as a goal explaining that in the
dark matter Paradigm but it's going to
be hard and you can't say because you
haven't explained it yet Dark Matter
isn't real it's it's a paradigmatic
difficult problem it's like saying you
know I don't understand Consciousness
therefore let's change all the
fundamental laws of physics
why should we understand Consciousness
it's hard we'll get there eventually but
the fact that we're not there now is not
strong evidence that we have to change
the laws of physics and the same thing
is true for the rotation curves of
spiral galaxies so you know again
all of this is what in legal terms would
be testimony against interest I would
like it if gravity were modified I have
written papers about modifying gravity
I've I've had many more thoughts about
modifying gravity that did not quite
make it into papers because they didn't
quite work that would be cool that'll be
fun that'd be awesome but it would also
both be in violation of our intuition
from effective field Theory and in
apparent violation of the data and these
days there are plenty of Plucky people
who keep trying to modify gravity but
secretly they're adding new stuff which
does all the work that ordinary Dark
Matter does so they should be compared
to other Dark Matter theories in terms
of how natural the parameters are how
effective the predictions are
Etc one way or the other Dark Matter
exists but we don't know what it is dark
medicine have to be a particle
necessarily it acts particle-like but
maybe they're microscopic black holes or
something like that completely Allowed
by the data so that's a perfectly valid
worry right the fact that we have very
very good evidence that dark matter
exists and yet we don't know what it is
that's a puzzle you know that's not a
crisis to have a puzzle we don't know
the answer to that's a good thing that's
the kind of thing that gets science
going when you have a puzzle that makes
you think about things and maybe you can
improve upon your understanding of the
world and it is not as if we are lacking
in options for what the Dark Matter
might be
we know again a lot about the dark
matter we know that it's dark in other
words it does not interact directly with
electromagnetism with light with photons
and that's how we get most of our
information about the universe out there
so that's an important fact about the
dark matter we know that it is cold
that's a new thing we didn't back in my
day when I started out uh hot dark
matter and warm Dark Matter were both
very popular what that means is how fast
the Dark Matter particles are moving in
the early Universe not so much today
they could be moving very quickly in the
early universe and then have cooled off
today but if they were moving very
quickly before recombination then they
would have smoothed out the density
fluctuations that grow into galaxies and
stars too much so again on the basis of
data we have excellent reason to believe
the dark matter is cold as well as dark
we also know that it is collisionless
more or less less collisionless amongst
itself now in other words Dark Matter
unlike ordinary matter does not Clump
together
we think that the reason why ordinary
matter dominates at the center of a
galaxy is because ordinary particles
hydrogen atoms for example can bump into
each other they're even though a
hydrogen atom is neutral it's made of
electrically charged particles so in the
bumping the hydrogen atoms can give off
photons and lose energy they can
dissipate they can fall into the center
of a gravitational potential well the
evidences from mapping out where dark
matter is the dark matter doesn't do
this even though the Galaxy that you see
when you take a picture with jwst or
something like that this is beautiful
compact structure the dark matter is in
a big puffy Halo slightly concentrated
near the middle but mostly diffuse
because there's nothing to cool it off
there's nothing to allow it to lose
energy and sink down to the bottom of
the gravitational potential it is mostly
collisionless
I say mostly because plenty of people
again myself included I've been in this
game for a long time I played with
various different ideas have explored
the possibility that dark matter does
interact more or less noticeably with
itself now there's different ways to
interact the kinds of interactions that
have been imagined for Dark Matter
particles that would be of astrophysical
interest have mostly been elastic
collisions in other words the little
dark matter particles even though they
rarely interact when they do so it's
kind of like billiard balls bouncing
into each other there is no dissipation
of their energy into emitting photons or
anything because they don't interact
under electromagnetism
even there my impression of the current
state of the art is there's not a lot of
parameter space in which that's allowed
but I think it is an open possibility
still now I did with various colleagues
including Mark kaminkowski uh Matthew
Buckley Lottie Ackerman proposed an idea
where there would be an entirely new
copy of electromagnetism dark
electromagnetism so that you could
actually have dark matter particles
coupled to a massless U1 gauge field
right a dark Photon and it turns out
there's actually a lot of parameter
space where that's okay because if the
interaction is weak enough if the fine
structure constant in the Dark Sector is
sufficiently small then you're actually
not going to give off a lot of radiation
and then you can start thinking about
dark atoms and dark chemistry and things
like that but it's more for fun because
the data tell you that the dark matter
is pretty smoothly distributed compared
to ordinary matter if there is any
interesting chemistry electromagnetism
level physics in the dark matter sector
it's much more feeble than it is in the
ordinary matter sector
and the final thing we know is that
adiabatic fact we mentioned before when
you have the density perturbations in
the early Universe the density
perturbations in the dark matter track
those in the ordinary matter this is
both exactly what you would expect from
inflationary cosmology or something like
that as a theory where those density
fluctuations came from and is also what
is more or less insisted upon by the
data that we have about where the dark
matter is and where the ordinary matter
is so that's a good amount of constraint
right the dark matter is dark it's cold
it's non-disipative and it is adiabatic
when in its density fluctuations but
that still leaves you a huge number of
possible candidates Martin Reese former
mindscape guest uh once said that
there's so many plausible Dark Matter
candidates it would be shocking if there
wasn't Dark Matter out there in the
universe I'm not sure if that's true or
not but think of it this way there's no
reason why in all the possible laws of
physics all the particles out there have
to be easily noticeable to you that's
just not how the universe is set up
so there's a task to be done if you're a
particle physicist invent come up with
plausible models for particles that
would be cold dark Etc and also have the
right Relic abundance that's the
crucially crucially important point you
have a prediction from the early
universe and the particle physics
properties of whatever model you have as
to how many particles are left over
after the universe expands and cools
that's something you can calculate
that's something that every graduate
student who does early Universe
cosmology is trained to do at a young
age calculate the Relic abundance of
your favorite Dark Matter candidate
so you can do that and you the easiest
thing to imagine is that your dark
matter particle used to be in thermal
equilibrium so it's interacting enough
even though it doesn't interact by
electromagnetism it interacts via some
other forests enough with ordinary
matter Etc that there was a time when
they were interacting with each other
relatively frequently right Dark Matter
particles were interconverting with
ordinary manner we don't know that to be
true I'm just saying that's the first
thing that you might guess that's a
natural starting point and then there's
basically one parameter that tells you
on the basis of how strong those
interactions are how many particles you
have left over at the end of the day The
Relic abundance and the answer is that
the strength of the interactions you
need for a cold dark Relic particle to
have the right abundance to be the dark
matter is basically the interaction
strength of the weak interactions of
particle physics this is called the wimp
Miracle whimsar weekly interacting
massive particles the miracle is just
the idea that if you go backwards and
ask how strong does interaction have to
be to get you the right Relic abundance
of dark matter the answer is roughly a
known quantity the interaction strength
of the weak interactions of particle
physics
so the word weak in weakly interacting
massive particle doesn't just mean not
very strong it means specifically the
weak interactions that we know about
from existing standard model particle
physics
now that's a little bit of an
exaggeration this wimp Miracle idea it
turns out there's a bunch of free
parameters in there that you might not
have paid close attention to but
actually do have an impact on what The
Relic abundance is so there's room
there's more than a little bit of wiggle
room there's a couple of order magnitude
Waters of magnitude a wiggle room in
terms of how much Relic abundance you
get but roughly speaking you know that's
a promising thing because if you think
about where were our brains 50 years ago
when the standard model was coming
online
there's another puzzle with the weak
interaction so we're going to get to in
just a second which is called the
hierarchy problem uh why does the mass
of the Higgs boson or more generally why
is the electroweak scale the energy
scale characteristic of the electroweak
interactions why is it so different from
the Planck mass or the grand unified
scale or whatever higher scale that you
might have so people imagine there's
different physics that kicks in at the
electro weak scale to help explain that
hierarchy problem that would imply there
are new particles at the weak scale at
this energy scale which is roughly
between a hundred and a thousand billion
electron volts so hundred and thousand
times the mass of the proton at that
energy scale there might be new
particles that we haven't seen yet they
would be weakly interacting they'd be
associated with the weak interactions
and they would be massive so in other
words just on very basic General grams
it's very natural to assume that there
are we cleaner interacting massive
particles out there
again that's their wiggle there's wiggle
room here right you don't need to have
particles that are that qualify as wimps
especially because there's an extra
property these particles should have
that I should mention which is that they
should be stable right not only neutral
not only electrically neutral and not
interacting with photons but they can't
Decay away very quickly and it's pretty
easy in particle physics to invent new
heavy particles that decay away very
quickly you have to work a little bit to
make particles that don't Decay if
they're very massive so you can do it
it's not hard but there's certainly no
demand that there must be particles
there they're natural but they're not
necessary Okay so
this is a natural prediction not not
prediction but expectation that there
are weekly interacting massive particles
that would naturally be the Dark Matter
this is the reason why weekly
interacting massive particles have for a
long time then the favored candidates
for being the dark matter because it's
not just that you're inventing them to
be the dark matter
there's something that pops out
naturally of other theories that you
invented for other reasons okay that's a
very common thing in particle physics if
you have all these puzzles around and
you could you know invent new particle
physics or particles or phenomena or
ideas puzzle by puzzle but if you can
get one idea that explains two puzzles
that's considered better right a little
bit more uh elegant or parsimonious or
something like that and so new particles
at the electro weak scale might help you
with both the Dark Matter problem and
the hierarchy problem and maybe other
problems of electroweak physics who
knows
so
we have launched programs to look for
these particles it's not like we haven't
looked and there's a very big
experimental program on the agenda very
and it's ongoing it's not like we're
planning in the future it is going on
right now and in fact we have not seen
weekly interacting massive particle dark
matter and we could have seen it already
Okay let's be super duper honest
um if you were asking people 20 years
ago I bet a lot of them would have bet
at 50 50 that by now we would have
detected weekly interacting massive dark
matter in experiments and we have not
yet so that should decrease our Credence
in the wimp idea how much it decreases
it well you know that's going to depend
on what your priors were and things like
that but I actually did the exercise of
going back and looking at papers that
were written 20 or 25 years ago about
what we should expect the dark matter
density to be and how much we can do
with various experiments in ruling out
the parameter space and I compared it to
what the current limits are this was a
couple years ago so maybe limits have
changed a little bit but very very
roughly speaking our current experiments
have ruled out about 50 percent of the
expected parameter space for weekly
interacting massive dark matter
so 50 again very very roughly
um but it's not one percent it's not 99
okay so that's an interesting number
because that means that yeah there
should be some noticeable decrease in
your Credence that the wimp idea is the
right
particle the right model the right
hypothesis for explaining the dark
matter but you shouldn't have given up
on it entirely I mean fifty percent of
the parameter space is noticeable but
not overwhelming right there's still a
whole another 50 out there to be tested
and yeah what could you do except build
better experiments bigger experiments uh
the Xenon experiment has for a while now
been one of the best out there at ruling
out parameter space for dark matter and
they're going to keep going they're
going to build bigger uh detectors with
more room to what they're doing is
basically you have dark matter all
around you if they are wimps then there
are dark matter particles around you
flying through your body right now not
interacting very much uh but you build a
detector which Waits For Those rare
times when Dark Matter particles will
interact with ordinary atoms deposit
some energy and you detect that energy
that's what you're trying to look for
and hadn't haven't seen it yet it's a
very very very difficult thing to do
because there are other things in the
world that could bump into an atom and
deposit some energy things that have
nothing to do with dark matter that's
why it's a very tricky thing to do it's
the backgrounds that really get you
but okay so the wimp possibility is very
natural very compelling we've ruled out
much of the parameter space but nowhere
near all of it now we also have other
candidates right we've had other
candidates for decades now the the
traditional second place favorite
candidate is the Axion particle the
Axion is an entirely different Beast
than the wimp it is much much lighter so
a typical wimp again it's going to be
hundreds of billions of electron volts
hundreds of gev or something like that
of course people are clever so they try
different things with Lighter dark
matter particles and that's that's fun
that's full employment for particle
astrophysicists the Axion is a much much
lighter particle it has a similar it
hypothetically we don't know if it
exists but it would have a similar mass
to neutrinos right something like a tiny
fraction of a single electron bulb much
lighter than electrons and things like
that maybe 10 to the minus 5 electron
volts 10 is for for axions and what is
an Axion it is it was a particle that
came out of once again a completely
different direction it was not invented
to be the Dark Matter this came out of
that uh you know those triumphant days
in the 1970s were putting the standard
model together it was realized that
there was a single puzzle there's more
than one puzzle but there was one puzzle
that hadn't got a lot of attention
called the strong CP problem
you may have heard that there are these
symmetries in the standard model or
would-be symmetries that are broken
they're called c p and t c is particle
anti-particle symmetries that's called
charge conjugation positive charges turn
to negative charges and and vice versa p
is parity and T is time reversal
invariance individually the physics and
the standard model violates all these
symmetries but the combination of them
CPT is actually conserved and in the
weak interactions in particular you can
see all these different things being
violated in experiments
the strong interactions appear to
preserve c p and t separately and that's
okay but it turns out if you think about
it hard it would not have been difficult
for the strong interactions to violate
CP it is very easy to write down a term
in the standard model particle physics
there will be a strongly interacting
term that would violate the combination
of charge conjugation which is particle
anti-particle Symmetry and parity okay
but it's not violated so that's weird
why isn't it too easy like in other
areas of the standard model if something
is possible it happens but there this
particular term seems to be zero even
though I mean the the experimental
limits are that is 10 to minus 9 or 10
to the minus 10 or less or something
like that no reason that we know of for
it to be that so um Roberto peche and
Helen Quinn back in the 1970s proposed a
model now called the pitch Aquin model
cleverly enough that invented a new
symmetry that would explain why there is
no CP violation in the strong
interactions and it was quickly realized
by Frank wilcheck former mindscape guest
and Stephen Weinberg separately that the
new symmetry that was being proposed
would come along with a new particle
Frank wilcheck named it the Axion after
a laundry detergent that he saw in
Europe there is a there is a
relationship there with axial currents
and things like that but basically he
was amused by the idea that this laundry
detergent sounded like an elementary
particle so the name has stuck the Axion
so the Axion is a spin-off a spandrel if
you like from an attempt to solve what
is called the strong CP problem and the
Axion has two parameters in it one
parameter is more or less fixed by
physics which is the strong interaction
scale what we call the qcd scale the
scale at which the strong interactions
really become strong but the other is
the peche Quinn scale pechen Quinn
invented this new mechanism a new energy
scale comes along with it we have no
idea what that scale is so we can
therefore pick that scale to be whatever
we want based on doing experiments
turns out that even though the Axion is
very very light the way it is produced
in the early universe is completely
different from the way that wimps are
produced the Axion was never in
equilibrium it interacts so weakly with
ordinary matter that it was never being
produced and converting back and forth
between ordinary matter so it has never
been hot it was never high temperature
okay it is basically produced at zero
temperature in the early universe
so we can be both light and nevertheless
be cold dark matter
and what you can do is you can say is
there a value of the pet Shay Quinn
scale such that The Relic density of
axions is what you need to be the dark
matter the answer you'll be unsurprised
to hear is yes you can absolutely do
that so that gives you a Target to shoot
for because you would like to
experimentally detect these axions now
the axions are sort of they have a
smaller constituency than the wimps do
because as I said the wimps are often
part of a much bigger structure that try
to extend the physics at the electro
weak scale so we have not put as much
effort into looking for axions
experimentally there have been there are
ongoing experiments to look for it we
haven't found it yet but we also haven't
ruled out as much of the viable
parameter space maybe 20 percent of the
Axion parameter space that's very very
roughly lit that's literally me looking
at plots and going yeah about 20 of the
rounder space is ruled out so maybe
someone who's an expert knows more but
the point is we haven't been as
successful because we haven't tried this
hard to find dark matter axions so
that's still completely viable Theory I
mean I literally just recently wrote a
paper about how axions might help us
create primordial magnetic fields so the
physics of axions is still very very
interesting and an ongoing concern
and of course these two theories wimps
and axions are not at all the only
theories the like I said they are both
examples of theories where the proposed
Dark Matter candidate also solves
another problem which we like but if you
free yourself from that constraint and
just say I'm going to invent a dark
matter candidate then go dots right I
mean there are dozens probably hundreds
maybe hundreds is a lower limit on the
number of models that have been proposed
for Dark Matter again I'm responsible
for some of them not that many I've not
done a lot of work on Dark Matter uh but
it you know it's fun propose a model and
then of course you why do you propose a
model not just because no one else has
proposed it yet but because it has some
other interesting consequences either
experimentally or solve some other
problem in the early universe or
something like that and sadly some of
the models that are proposed would imply
that essentially we will never directly
detect the Dark Matter there are models
of Dark Matter were the only
interactions with ordinary matter or
through gravity basically
that would be sad right but the universe
isn't out there to make us happy so
we're doing our best to find the dark
matter to propose ideas that are
experimentally testable and we may or
may not succeed that's just the reality
of it so in terms of the crisis in
physics idea
is this a crisis
uh I know it's certainly not a crisis I
mean
you can be sad that we haven't found the
Dark Matter particle yet uh you can be
irked that nature is not being nice to
us but I think basically the strategies
being pursued are exactly the right
strategies you as a theorist put on your
thinking caps and try to think of what
the Dark Matter could be as an
experimentalist you try to find it in
the experimentalists and the theorists
talk to each other about the best ways
of doing that there are multiple
prospects for what the Dark Matter might
be again unfortunately there
experimental tests are utterly different
from each other an experiment that is
looking for wimps will not be able to
find axions and vice versa and if we're
honest there are models out there where
no experiment is going to find them so
what are you supposed to do in that
situation and I I think that what you're
supposed to do is what we're doing and
you're supposed to look supposed to
judge the different models on their
relative plausibility and you're
supposed to spend some money in some
time and some effort in experimentally
searching for these different
possibilities relative to your
expectation as to how likely they are it
makes perfect sense that we spend more
money looking for wimps than axions so
far because in the Judgment of most
physicists they are the more likely
candidate not by a lot so we also do
axions and we're also doing other things
as well but I don't know what else
people would want one to do right nature
is nature it's gonna give you the
experimental results when it chooses to
not when we demand it we cannot just
stamp our feet and say find the Dark
Matter tomorrow or else that's just not
a viable strategy
I think that's all I got to say about
dark matter there's also Dark Energy but
there's not that much to say about Dark
Energy it is 70 of the energy density of
the Universe
um it is less cut and dried about Dark
Energy existing because in the case of
dark energy there's a lot less
specificity in the data that we have
about it we know that how much of it
there is and we know that it doesn't
evolve very quickly we know that it's
smoothly distributed through space as
far as we can tell and it's
approximately constant in density over
time
that's good that's some information that
really constrains things but it's much
less specific information than we have
for dark matter for dark matter we can
literally map out where it is right you
can see these gorgeous maps that are
made from gravitational lensing studies
and that's very very specific info
whereas Dark Energy we basically have a
number how much it is and all the other
numbers that might exist like how much
it changes from place to place how much
it changes from moment to moment so far
all those other numbers are consistent
with zero so for Dark Energy it's
absolutely plausible that you could try
to replace Dark Energy with modified
gravity again this is something I have
done and people have followed up in many
many papers about that stuff it's an
actively pursued area but
um I gotta say I think it's probably
just a constant and again this is super
duper testimony against interest because
a lot of my papers a lot of my uh most
highly cited papers are about either
getting rid of dark energy and replacing
it with modified gravity or thinking
about the consequences of some dynamical
theory of dark energy most most
obviously if you have a Axion like
particle but instead of 10 to the minus
5 electron volts it's 10 to the minus 33
electron volts some incredibly tiny mass
then that can be the dark energy rather
than being the dark matter it can be a
quintessence-like field where the the
field evolves very very slowly over time
and uh you can make an experimental
prediction based on that which is called
birefringence the idea that photons
traveling through this time-dependent
quintessence field will slowly rotate
their polarizations from the cosmic
microwave background to today and as I
mentioned I did a solo podcast sometime
back on the screwy universe so look that
up if you're interested in these ideas
but there is a claim out there that you
can kind of maybe see this by
refringence in the known data that we
have right now on the cosmic microwave
background polarization I think it's not
yet
to the level of statistical significance
where we can claim that it's really
there so I'm being very very cautious
about it in fact if I were to bet I'd
say if I were forced to bat gun to my
head I think that the chances that it's
that the signal is is truly a signal of
birefringence rather than just some
random fluctuation or experimental error
is less than 50 percent it's more than
five percent okay so it's absolutely
worth following up on I absolutely hope
it's there that would be great but the
simplest explanation for the dark energy
is just that it's a cosmological
constant it's that vacuum energy that we
were talking about before
it's the simplest explanation and it
fits all the data perfectly so far so be
very very careful when people say we
know nothing about what the dark energy
is what do you mean we know nothing
again we know some of its properties and
we have a really good candidate for what
it is it's the cosmological constant
it's the vacuum energy we're in this
weak understanding phase where there are
also other candidates you could have
some slowly varying scalar field or you
could modify gravity in some way all of
those are worse theories in the sense
that they give rise to new problems you
didn't already have without solving any
of the other problems that the
cosmological constant has but they're
viable experimentally and so we should
take them seriously but it's not that we
are just clueless you know we have a
perfectly good idea of what it could be
that fits all the data we're trying to
pin down whether or not all the other
theories are still viable or not the
more data we get the less viable they
become but they're still out there we
have to think about it again
not sure what else you would have people
do like that's what we got to do we
propose ideas and we experimentally test
them by the way in both cases
in the cases of both dark matter and
dark energy
um you might roll your eyeballs a little
bit at the tendency of theorists to just
keep proposing models right keep
proposing theories of what the Dark
Matter could be the dark energy could be
there are many many many many many many
many many models out there doesn't it
get a little tiresome but the crucially
important thing to realize is that when
you say Let's do an experiment or let's
do an astrophysical observation to test
these ideas
that idea of doing an experiment or
doing an observation is not independent
of your theoretical model
different theories are going to be
constrained by different experiments
again the experiments that constrain
wimps are completely different from the
experiments that constrain axions so if
you don't sit down and write down the
explicit model you can't experimentally
test the idea you might there might very
well be some experiment that we could
easily do for you know hundred thousand
dollars that would instantly let us
detect the dark matter but we don't know
what the experiment is yet because the
theorists haven't yet invented the model
that makes that prediction okay so all
of these theorists turning out new
models yes it can look a little you know
your eyes could glaze over if you're not
actually one of these people but it's
crucially important because one of them
might be right and the right one might
have some very clever unusual unique
experimental signature that we don't
know about yet Theory and experiment
depend on each other and one of the ways
they depend on each other is the
experimentalists need theorists to tell
them what to look for so that activity
going on is actually crucially important
so I don't think that anything about
dark matter and dark energy represent
crises in any possible sense they
represent good old-fashioned physics
puzzles that we don't know the answers
to yet we have good ideas about what
they could be we're trying to test those
ideas experimentally as well as coming
up with new ideas that might suggest new
experimental tests that's as healthy as
it is possible for a field to be
progress is slow
so what that's not the physicist fault
it's not the fault of the people trying
to do the work they would all like the
progress to be fast nature does not
always cooperate and that's something we
have to learn to accept
so that's one area that people get a
little irked about the whole Dark Matter
Dark Energy thing let's turn to the next
area I have three areas I'm gonna give
them away one is the Dark Matter Dark
Energy stuff another is naturalness
problems within the core Theory and the
third is quantum gravity which I'm sure
you've heard about so let's talk about
the naturalness problems the naturalness
problems in the core Theory come about
because we have this idea and it's not a
very philosophically respectable idea I
think it I think there is a
philosophically respectable idea buried
in there but I think that the
philosophers and the physicists have not
really sat down to hash out what it
should be
but the germ of the idea is some
features of a theory like the core
Theory look natural to us
some features do not
what does it mean for a feature to look
natural to us and Gerard tuft who's a
famous physicist one of the great
masters of quantum field theory in the
70s and 80s and so forth put forward a
certain definition of naturalness in the
context of quantum field Theory having
to do with the existence of a small
parameter is natural if a symmetry is
restored when that small parameter is
literally zero but there's other Notions
of naturalness that we use at a more
informal level and we can talk about
like why should we have some expectation
that something is natural the Rough and
Ready
thing that we have in mind when we say
that things in the standard model are
natural or not is if you have a
dimensionless number
so not like a mass or something like
that but maybe a ratio of two masses
that's a dimensionless number if you
have a dimensionless number that is very
very tiny
much much smaller than one or contrary
wise its reciprocal is way way greater
than one okay if you find such a number
for no good reason like it's the
combination of a whole bunch of things
that really should add up we think to
something of order Unity but it doesn't
that's a naturalness problem that that's
something that looks wrong to us and I
already mentioned the strong CP problem
that's one of the naturalness problems
there's two other big famous ones in the
core Theory one is the hierarchy problem
and that's the ratio of the scale of the
electric weak interactions which is of
order couple hundred Geb geds a billion
electron volts to the Planck scale or to
if you think that there's some
unification scale up there near the
plank scale then same thing so very
roughly speaking the weak scale divided
by the Planck scale in the real world is
something like 10 to the minus 15. okay
that's a tiny number and the reason why
there's some meat on these bones is
because if you think of the electro weak
scale in the context of quantum field
Theory it looks like it is a combination
of various different contributions from
various different things okay there are
quantum Corrections if you start with a
classical Theory there's Quantum
corrections to that classical result you
should add them all together Etc and
there's no reason for them to cancel and
they're generally big
so very roughly speaking we would expect
the quantum Corrections that we know and
love from the standard model of particle
physics would increase the electro weak
scale if you just started with some
classical value and it would increase it
all the way up to the blank scale
there's no reason for it not to but it
doesn't it's 10 to the minus 15 times
the Planck scale we're up very very
roughly speaking
that's the hierarchy problem why is
there such a large hierarchy between the
electric weak scale and the plank scale
the other problem is of course the
cosmological constant problem it's
almost exactly the same story The Vacuum
energy the cosmological constant could
very well be thought of as getting
combat getting contributions from
various different sources classical
Quantum Etc and it should be up there
near the plank scale it is not depending
on how you use units to measure it in if
you use units of energy density the
energy density in the vacuum is 10 to
the minus 120 times the Planck scale
value now that's the famous number that
is supposed to be the largest
discrepancy between expectation and
reality in all of physics I think it's
perfectly valid to take the one-quarter
power of that that take 10 to minus 120
raise it to the power one over four why
because dimensionally this energy
density the that you're looking at has
units of energy to the fourth power
once you go into natural units when H
bar equals C equals one that's what
particle businesses do everything is
measured in energy to some power
energy density is energy to the fourth
power so the actual discrepancy in
energy scale between the vacuum energy
and the plank scale is not 10 to the
minus 120 but 10 to the minus 30. okay
10 to the minus 30 is still a really
small number this is a giant discrepancy
between
um what we see and what we might expect
now in the case of the hierarchy problem
the thing is that the electroweak scale
is has been historically a little bit
high for us to look at directly that was
the motivation behind building Large
Hadron Collider would have been the
motivation behind building the
superconducting super collider which
remember would have gotten to even
higher energies than the LHC would have
but we canceled it because in the late
1990s we were on a drive to cut the
budget deficit so the SSC was started
but never finished and the tunnel was
basically filled in we're never going to
do that so the LHC Large Hadron Collider
at CERN outside Geneva is our best look
near the electric weak scale and because
of the hierarchy problem
um there was this very very strong
expectation nation that once we actually
looked at the physics of the electro
weak scale we would find some kind of
new physics
there are specific examples of what it
could be supersymmetry or extra
Dimensions or whatever strong Dynamics
there's various different options on the
table but there was a strong feeling
that because of the hierarchy problem
there had to be something going on at
the electro weak scale and whatever that
something was would give rise to a whole
bunch of new particles okay maybe they'd
be super symmetric particles
supersymmetry if you know is a
hypothetical symmetry between bosons and
fermions
from the mathematical Quantum field
Theory perspective it's an extremely
natural thing to think about
supersymmetry and it turns out to have
all sorts of nice properties it helps
make calculations easier you know it has
very very specific predictions
experimentally and so forth and it could
help solve the hierarchy problem and it
could give us a dark matter candidate
the neutralino would be a supersymmetric
particle that would be a candidate to be
a wimp to be a weakly interacting
massive particle so it seemed if you're
thinking you know 20 years ago again you
would have absolutely every right to
think that by now we would have both
found the dark matter in direct searches
for dark matter the weekly interacting
massive neutralino and we would have
found a whole bunch of new particles at
the LHC because the LHC looks at the
electric weak scale found the Higgs
boson right and it's looking for more
particles out there
didn't work didn't happen we have not
found any new particles it could have
been the case
that we turn on the LHC and gluinos are
just popping out of the detector and so
many of them that it's hard to miss them
right uh we haven't seen any not just
super symmetric particles but any
particles beyond what are already in the
core Theory now gotta be honest we're
not done yet we're nowhere near done the
Lac is still running still looking for
new things always creeping up to higher
energies higher luminosities
but it wasn't the easy nice thing that
we might have hoped for that we
certainly had crossed our fingers hoping
for
um they don't so far seem to be any new
particles at the electro weak scale
other than the Higgs boson which we knew
had to be there uh if if most models of
low energy supersymmetry had been right
then we would have seen a bunch of new
particles and we haven't so the
hierarchy problem is just there it's
just staring Us in the face now in
retrospect you might have reasoned in
the following way
the hierarchy problem is a discrepancy
between the electric weak scale at 100
GED and the Planck scale at 10 to the 18
gev or whatever
whereas the cosmological constant
problem is a very similar looking
problem but the energy scale of the
vacuum is like 10 to the minus 3
electron volts so that's what 10 to the
minus 12
GV which is very different than 10 to
the plus 18 GED that's the 30 orders of
magnitude difference and we don't see
any new particles near the vacuum energy
scale that keep its scale so much lower
so maybe that was not a right thing to
think about the electro weak scale
either
fine but we don't know what the right
thing is so again we're just doing our
honest best right we had a puzzle the
hierarchy problem still do it hasn't
gone away okay but it you know it's been
a major motivation for many years now
and we had good plausible candidates to
explain it
and so far there's no evidence for any
of them and that's a real fact that
particle physicists have to face up to
so what do you do well there's a couple
different things you could do like one
thing to do is just Bull on ahead and
just keep going just keep coming up with
theories that would help to explain the
heart our hierarchy problem and just
imagine building even higher energy
particle accelerators to test those
theories it is you have to be honest it
is more of a fishing Expedition now the
Lac and the SSC that that got canceled
they had a Target to shoot for the
electroweak scale right we didn't see
haven't seen yet anyway I really hope
that like the next month shows up a
whole bunch of new particles and I can
throw away this whole podcast but right
now we haven't seen any new particles at
the LHC
um so there's no very strong theoretical
prediction that says oh just go one
order of magnitude higher and you'll see
a bunch of particles okay they might be
there the hierarchy problem is still the
hierarchy problem but whatever particles
you discover will be have a little bit
of extra energy themselves they're not
at the electric weak scale they would
have to be at a higher energy a higher
Mass so it's a little bit less clear
that they would count as a solution to
the hierarchy problem
but what are you going to do like again
nature is not being kind to us in this
case we have a puzzle uh we're trying
our best to solve it right I think
that's what we're supposed to do now
there is another strategy besides just
pulling on uh straightforwardly which is
rethink your assumptions right take a
step back think about okay we have the
cosmological constant problem the strong
CP problem the hierarchy problem these
are all these puzzles that numbers that
are in the standard model and could have
been of order one are much much smaller
what is going on with that
okay that's an absolutely valid thing to
do is in fact is my preferred way of
moving forward I absolutely have tried I
have sat down I have ideas none of my
ideas have been very good so far about
really rethinking you know Quantum field
Theory effective field Theory
naturalness the structure of space time
itself to somehow make it more plausible
that either the cosmotional constant or
the electroweak scale should be much
smaller than we naturally expect but you
know easier said than done it's very
easy to say yes rethink your deep
assumptions okay but the Deep
assumptions have been super productive
and successful at explaining data up
until today so it's hard to rethink them
without just breaking everything that
all that represent all the successes
we've had so far so by all means rethink
the assumptions but that marching order
is not very specific it doesn't tell you
what direction to march in which
assumption are we supposed to be
rethinking again I'm trying other people
are trying
um but it's hard to know what to do so
this this absence of particles
new particles at the electric weak scale
is really concerning to the future of
particle physics in my mind
um I think that in my mind it's
absolutely worth building a bigger more
energetic particle accelerator to look
beyond what the LIC is able to see but
in good conscience I can't promise you
we'll see anything anything new will
ReDiscover the standard model of course
I think it's worth it because it would
truly expand our understanding of nature
if we do find something but I'm not the
one writing the checks right so I have
to be honest about what the expectations
are I think this is a truly difficult
problem is it a crisis I don't know
again I don't think that nature ever
said is going to be easy right part of
the joy part of the challenge of this
game is that the puzzles are hard the
the
things that we think about nature are
tentative and subject to revision and
nature is tricky and we're in regimes
where our intuition is nowhere near good
enough to make progress so again I think
what we're doing is what we're supposed
to be doing I don't see any crisis here
I see a sad situation where we didn't
find as many particles yet as we wanted
to but that's different than a crisis
that's not because the physicists
themselves have been doing anything
wrong
and then the final thing I want to talk
about is the idea of quantum gravity
right something that we don't understand
perfectly well I'm sure you've heard
that
um what should we do uh we do have this
effective field Theory weak gravity
understanding of quantum gravity that
works perfectly fine but we would like
to understand the origin of the universe
the quantum nature of black holes stuff
like that and here the other there's a
slightly interesting story to tell
because
it's no doubt I don't know what you've
heard if you're out there if you're not
within physics itself there's a
different feeling out there in the
public than there is within physics
departments within physics departments
it is still true that string theory is
very healthy
and is by far the most popular way of
thinking about quantum gravity
you might have heard that string theory
is dead no one does it anymore that's
all completely raw okay now it might be
wrong like string theory might not be
the Right theory that's absolutely true
but within professional physics circles
it is still by far the most popular way
of thinking about quantum gravity why is
that
well there's different explanations we
can go into the details about the
history but the main thing is that in
you know the string theory was born in
the late 1960s as a theory that tried to
tackle the strong interactions right
this is before we knew about qcd and
quarks and whatever and people realized
that the experimental evidence of
different particles that were strongly
interacting might have well been fit by
thinking about instead of particles
thinking about strings in fact what we
now know is going on is that because the
strong interactions are strong because
of confinement if you have two quarks
it's not like an electron and a proton
in a hydrogen atom where they have these
electromagnetic fields that spread out
in all directions around them
if you have two quarks the gluon field
that attaches them together is basically
confined to a little tube from one Quark
to the other Quark so it looks kind of
like a string you can imagine that
little tube of gluons connecting the two
quarks together could stretch and bounce
it could whirl around right it could
have some angular momentum there's
various modes of vibration that it could
have that are kind of like the
vibrational modes of a string
so we understand why this this
collection of strongly interacting
particles not quarks but the combined
particles the mesons and the baryons why
you might have thought that thinking of
them in terms of strings rather than
quarks and gluons was the right way to
go but when people thought about this
hypothesis that the world is made of
strings rather than particles they kept
running into the puzzle the problem as
they thought of it that the theory kept
predicting gravity
it kept predicting a spin 2 particle in
particular which has all the properties
of the graviton
So eventually they realize well look
gravity exists let's just take it
seriously as a theory of gravity so that
was a a research project in the 1970s it
was not a popular research project it
was like five people working I don't
know maybe more than five but a very
tiny number of people working on it very
hard
and one of the reasons why it was not
that popular is because well there's a
couple reasons number one no one in
1970s very very few people were thinking
about quantum gravity they were still
having fun with the standard model and
putting that together right gravity
seemed a little bit inaccessible
but number two what we've learned by our
studies of quantum field theory in the
20th century especially these gauge
theories that I told you about earlier
is they're very very delicate in some
way if you just write down a new Theory
and say I have a gauge Theory and hear
some matter and here's some gauge forces
it's very very easy for that theory to
be ill-defined for there to be reasons
why it won't work whether it's because
there are negative energy particles or
more commonly there's something called
the anomaly that you get when you
quantize a gauge Theory you have a
symmetry right the whole idea of a gauge
theory is you're based on some Symmetry
and it turns out that you can write down
a symmetry of a classical Theory
but then when you quantize the theory
the quantum theory no longer has that
symmetry you've broken the Symmetry by
the process of quantization this is
called an anomaly
and this is deadly if you have a gauge
theory in particle physics the gauge
symmetries are super duper important so
there's a requirement if you have a
well-defined gauge theory that you not
have an anomaly in it that the Symmetry
is not broken by quantization
and everyone thought that string theory
was just so complicated and all these
random symmetries running around that
ultimately you would find some anomalies
in it and it wouldn't work so in 1984
two things are happening in 1984. number
one we had experimentally found the w
and z bosons okay so it was pretty clear
that what we now call the standard model
of particle physics was on the right
track basically 1984 was around the year
where particle physicists said yeah I
think I think we got this one figured
out I think we have all the data
explained we've made predictions that we
haven't yet tested in 1984 we hadn't yet
found the top Quark the Higgs Etc but it
was clear that the basic picture was on
the right track so where do you go next
what do you do and the other thing that
happened in 1984 is that uh Michael
green and John Schwartz showed that in
string theory all the anomalies cancel
there are no anomalies in super String
Theory so it's super String Theory
because String Theory again
supersymmetry the Symmetry between
bosons and fermions makes life easier in
many ways whatever Theory you have if
you make the supersymmetric version of
it it's nicer uh the Infinities go away
you can calculate things better so super
String Theory it turns out
supersymmetries I don't want to say
necessary but super duper helpful in
making String Theory well defined so in
1984 Green and Schwartz realized that
super string theory is a perfectly
viable theory of quantum gravity it's
finite it there's no Infinities in the
renormalization or anything like that
it's free of anomalies and it predicts
not only the existence of gravity but
the existence of other gauge forces
which might very well eventually end up
being the electromagnetic weak and
strong forces that we know about in the
real world there is a tiny problem that
it only works in 10-dimensional
space-time Okay so
that's no problem physicists are very
brave they know what to do take six of
the dimensions curl them up into a tiny
little ball and you can get a effective
four-dimensional effective field Theory
right and it was soon realized after
green and Schwartz's breakthrough that
there was a small number of different
possibilities at the level of the
10-dimensional theories there were only
five different theories that were
well-defined string theories so the
crucial thing the reason why I'm going
through that little bit of history is
at no point
did the community of theoretical
physicists say
let's do our best to think about quantum
gravity
that is not a moment that ever happened
because they were already like I said
very excited about field theory in the
standard model and the string theorists
were a tiny little minority that were
trying something completely different
and it's not that the community said
let's think about quantum gravity is
that the string theorist said here you
have a theory of quantum gravity right
here that is very compatible with
everything that we know otherwise and
might even be a theory of everything
that also explains the standard model
and so forth
so it wasn't that people sat around and
said what's the best way to quantize
gravity is that this theory of quantum
gravity fell in their lap people like Ed
whidden said this is a 21st century
theory that somehow found his way into
the 1980s and we're going to spend
decades figuring out what it's saying
now to be very very fair there was an
enormous amount of overhype about string
theory in the 1980s uh because because
it was potentially a Theory of
Everything people really got interested
in this idea could you predict not just
that there is gravity which is nice but
also predict all the standard model and
maybe some supersymmetric version of the
standard model and get the dark matter
and figure out what all the parameters
are and all those things that was
absolutely an ambition that people had
in string theory in the 1980s it didn't
work as you know we would have told you
if that had worked now it got worse over
time but also since I was there I can
tell you that even though string theory
was very very hyped there was a
bandwagon that was launched in the 1980s
people were still quite skeptical or at
least cautious about it many of the best
physics departments in the world didn't
hire any string theorists at the time
but because they weren't sure whether
the idea was just going to go away
whether it was just a fad it really this
the switch really flipped in the 90s
when we had what is called the second
Super string Revolution we had the first
revolution in 1984 with green and
Schwartz and the anomaly cancellations
in the 1990s Joe polczynski pointed out
that string theory is not just a theory
of strings there are also these things
called D Brains dirichlet Brains which
are not one-dimensional strings but some
of them are one-dimensional but there's
also two-dimensional brains
three-dimensional Brains
four-dimensional Brains Etc this is
brain
b-r-a-n-e a back construction out of
membrane okay so polczynski pointed out
the importance of these D brains for the
fundamental way of defining string
theory that became very exciting and
then Whitton quickly pointed out that in
fact what was going on is that what we
thought were five separate string
theories back in the 80s was just five
different limits of a single Theory
and in fact there's a sixth limit called
11 dimensional supergravity okay which
is not even a string theory but it's a
limit of this ER Theory this overall
Theory called M Theory
and then maldesena pointed out that this
idea of holography that had been bandied
about in the context of black holes by
tuft and suskind Etc
had this wonderful property that you
could implement it in what is called the
ads cfd correspondence where you have a
five-dimensional anti-decider space
which is a cosmological space time that
has a boundary at Infinity that you can
think of as flat space time in one lower
Dimension and there is you can imagine
defining a ordinary non-gravitational
Quantum field theory on the boundary
that is holographically equivalent to
the quantum gravity theory in the
anti-decider bulk this is all amazingly
you know exciting kind of stuff so M
Theory ads CFT dbrains and this is the
second Super string Revolution and now
people got convinced like a whole bunch
of physics departments that didn't have
any String Theory suddenly hired string
theorists
and
that's the good news the bad news is you
know these D brains kind of threw a
spanner into the works because back in
the 80s when you knew that string theory
was naturally defined in 10 dimensions
and you said okay we're gonna compactify
the extra Dimensions it we already knew
there is a lot of different ways to
compactify and this is the subject of
what are called kalabi Yao manifolds
people like Brian Greene who we had on
the podcast uh were one of the experts
um Andy strominger who we also had were
working on what kinds of clubbial
manifolds could you compactify on
once you had the D brains it turns out
there's like a gajillion more ways to
compactify the extra Dimensions
um and it became very clear that you
were not just going to start with M
Theory in 10 or 11 dimensions and
uniquely figure out why the standard
model of particle physics in four
dimensions is the physics that we
observe and in fact you can have what is
called a landscape of many many
different possibilities and the the
number that is traditionally trotted out
is 10 to the 500 but that's a totally
made up number some people think it's
smaller some people think it's Infinity
but there's certainly not any obvious
uniqueness in the way that you make the
journey from String Theory to the real
world
now just because nature is uh
mischievous this was about the same time
remember this mid 80s okay so Malta
saying is like I forget 97 or 98
then in 1998 we discovered the
acceleration of the universe remember
those those pesky astronomers told us
that there is a cosmodial constant and
this rocked the world as it should have
of theoretical physicists because the
idea that we had before for the
cosmological constant was you know this
number is way way way way smaller than
it should be it should be at the playing
scale it's 10 to the minus 120 or less
in my mind this is how theoretical
physicists thought at the time in my
mind I don't know why the cosmodial
constant is smaller than I think it
should be
but in the space of all possible
theories that I don't know yet but I
could imagine coming up with
it is easier for me to imagine some
mechanism that takes this big number and
squelches it all the way down to zero
then it is to imagine a new mechanism
that takes this big number and squelches
it down to 10 to the minus 120 times its
natural value
especially because that would be a weird
inexplicable coincidence with the value
of the vacuum energy and the value of
other energy densities in the universe
right you know we said right now now
that we know we've discovered it it's 70
vacuum energy 25 Dark Matter five
percent ordinary matter so that's 30
matter 70 vacuum energy but these two
quantities change with respect to each
other rather dramatically as the
universe expands the density of dark
energy stays constant as the universe
expands and the density of matter goes
down as the size of the universe cubed
because the volume goes up and the
number of particles stays the same
so it's a what is called a coincidence
problem why in the world is the current
ratio of vacuum energy to ordinary
energy of order one when it could be any
other number so most people before 1998
thought that we would eventually show
that the cosmological constant is zero
would come up with some theoretical
explanation for that but then it's not
zero probably if if the vacuum energy if
the reason why the universe is
accelerating really is the vacuum energy
so guess what there's this old idea that
people have been banded bending around
called the anthropic principle and the
Multiverse
the idea that if you have in the
universe different regions where the
local laws of physics are different
then by a selection effect we
complicated intelligent complex beings
would only find ourselves in the subset
of that Ensemble of different
possibilities that allowed for the
existence of complex organized life
forms right it's it's a selection effect
it's environmental selection it's the
same reason why we're not surprised that
we human beings live on the earth rather
than on the moon or on the sun even
though the sun is much bigger because
the conditions there are just not
hospitable to us in the solar system
there are conditions that are hospitable
to life and conditions that are
inhospitable of course we're going to
find ourselves in the hospitable region
so maybe this idea that goes back to the
1980s or even the 70s
maybe if the universe is like that maybe
if the universe is an ensemble of many
different local conditions some of which
are hospitable to life in some of which
are not
some of the conditions that we observe
around us can be explained by
environmental selection we can only find
ourselves in the regions that are
allowed and Stephen Weinberg in the
1980s had pointed out that the cosmodial
constant was a ripe Target for this kind
of reasoning
we didn't know said Weinberg why the
cosmological constant is so small but if
it were much bigger we wouldn't be here
to talk about it it would not allow for
the
formation of galaxies and the existence
of life and the long time span that the
Universe has and so on and so forth so
Weinberg pointed out that if that's the
right answer if there really is some
kind of cosmological Multiverse in which
the cosmological constant takes on
different values then we would actually
very naturally expect
the value of the vacuum energy to be
just big enough so that it's hard to
find but not impossible and so in 1998
that turned out to be what we found and
the question became are you going to
take this anthropic idea seriously and
if so you need a mechanism for making
the cosmological constant different in
different parts of the universe and
guess what this idea of the string
theory landscape fit perfectly into that
aspiration because
with inflationary cosmology plus the
string theory landscape you can very
easily make a Multiverse where the
cosmological constant takes on very
different values from place to place and
so reluctantly I don't think anyone was
enthusiastic about it maybe Andre Linde
but maybe no other people uh reluctantly
string theorists began to say maybe
we're not going to find the ultimate
answer to the cosmological constant
problem maybe it's just we're in one of
the 10 of the 500 ways of compactifying
the extra Dimensions that gives us the
right answer
so
a lot of people didn't like that a lot
of people still don't like that let me
be clear I don't want to go into too
many details here but String Theory
whether or not it's right we don't know
whether it's right but whether or not
it's right it's led to a lot of exciting
ideas that I think are very very likely
to be true even if String Theory isn't
true some of the ideas that have been
developed because of string theory I
personally think are extremely likely to
ultimately find a place in our theory of
quantum gravity these include ideas of
holography black hole complementarity
how to get information out of black
holes as they evaporate away the
relationship between Quantum information
and immersion space time many of these
things have been developed within the
umbrella of what we call String Theory
okay and I don't think that they are
going to go away
but there is a worry
has string theory
taking up all the oxygen has it
prevented other theories of quantum
gravity from getting the attention that
they deserve so in again I'll just give
you my personal opinion no it has not
really because there was never a moment
this is why I went through the the idea
that there was never a moment when the
community of physicists said yes let's
try to do quantum gravity the time is
right
gravity is a very weak Force you can't
make gravitons and detect them in a
particle accelerator gravitons exist
with almost you know 99.999 Credence
because of basic features of quantum
field Theory and general relativity but
they're weak they're weakly interacting
way way way more weekly interacting than
the actual weak interactions of particle
physics because if you want because the
playing scales are very high energy
scale gravity is correspondingly weak so
it is easy to do experiments on
classical gravity we do not know how to
do experiments in the regime where both
quantum mechanics and gravity are
simultaneously relevant and because of
that it's very hard to make progress in
quantum gravity so as a problem everyone
agrees that quantizing gravity is
important but when physicists decide
what to work on they don't just say well
what's important they say what's
important and what can we make progress
on okay this is a big reason why the
foundations of quantum mechanics have
been ignored for a long time because
people don't know how to make progress
on them so String Theory seemed to be an
example of progress that we just got
lucky with right a finite theory of
quantum gravity just falling in our laps
it might not be the right one there are
people out there you know one of my very
first
podcast interviews was with Carlo
ravelli and later I interviewed Lee
smallen these are both Advocates of the
loop quantum gravity approach to
quantizing gravity and
I'm just not that excited about Loop
quantum gravity it doesn't have the
promise and the fruitfulness that string
theory has it's you know it's kind of a
eat your vegetables here's the theory of
gravity let's try to quantize it and
hope for the best but and other people
will disagree you're welcome to disagree
I have not seen any of the ideas that
have been generated by people working in
String Theory come out of loop quantum
gravity or causal dynamical
triangulations or euclidean quantum
gravity or these various other
approaches that people think about I
think the string theory has been very
fruitful in other ideas that may or may
not be necessarily attached to string
theory but will still be very very
useful so I think that string theory has
been good for physics overall whether or
not it is overall whether or not turns
out to be the Right theory of nature
and another footnote there that I want
to add on which is that there's an idea
of unification right the theory of
everything that was the buzz phrase back
in the 1980s that we were going to take
gravity and unify it along with the
other forces so what is the back story
there you know Weinberg and Salam and
their friends back in the 60s figured
out in some sense how to unify
electromagnetism and the weak Force it's
kind of a cludgy unification because
there's still you know different age
symmetries running around but it was
super duper effective in terms of being
right it predicted all these things the
predictions came right Nobel prizes all
around uh and it was spectacularly
successful so that left out the strong
interactions right the electro week
theory is the electromagnetic and the
weak interactions it didn't you can just
tack on the strong interactions su3 qcd
but it's not unified with them so a very
very natural thing to do in the 1970s
was to try to unify
the electric weak interactions with the
strong interactions and that was a
challenge that people immediately took
up and the first famous example was
George I and glashau Howard George I and
Sheldon Glassell proposed an su-5 Grand
unified model and people were very
excited because it seemed to be the way
physics was going more and more
unification and also you made
experimental predictions uh one
prediction you made was kind of
unfortunate you predicted that there
were magnetic monopoles that were much
more dense than anything else in the
universe so that that prediction was not
borne out by reality and it was a major
major motivation for Alan Guth inventing
the inflationary Universe scenario in
1980 he pointed out you could inflate
away all the magnetic monopoles that had
been predicted by Grand unification
but the other experimental prediction
was that the proton is not completely
stable you've unified
quarks with leptons right strongly
interacting particles with non-strongly
interacting particles as a result you
make a quantitative prediction that the
proton will eventually decay
sometimes people talk about this as if
it's like existentially worrisome like
oh no even matter itself is not stable
that never bothered me like the the
lifetimes here we're talking about are
10 to 35 years or something like that
right we're not we're not worried about
this uh in a balance our investment for
portfolio kind of way but the nice thing
is
one Decay every 10 to the 35 years isn't
that often but what physicists know how
to do is get a lot of particles together
in the same place so you can wait around
and hope to see a proton decaying and
they did
wait around and hope they did not see
any protons decaying
so that was a blow right
um Grand unification Grand unification
is a label given to this idea of strong
plus Electro weak Theory being unified
it does not include gravity Grand
unified theories or guts as they were
called have nothing to do with gravity
they were very big Topic in the 1970s
they made a prediction that the proton
would Decay and it didn't
again as in many other cases uh
physicists are clever you don't give up
you say well okay we can still Grand
unify but we can change around some of
the parameters and some of the patterns
and we can increase the lifetime of the
proton so that you don't see it yet
absolutely Fair people did that but the
enthusiasm for Grand unification has
declined because it made a prediction
that didn't come true that's perfectly
Fair that's what should happen again no
crisis going on is still trying because
maybe it's true but you're less
enthusiastic than you were before
then in the 1980s with string theory
there was a first well-posed theory that
could unify in principle gravity with
all the other forces right so that was
very exciting and people worked on that
and that was The Theory of Everything
so you still to this day now it's 2023
see a bunch of non-professional
physicists thinking very hard about
unifying things unification one form of
unification or another and what they've
missed is that it's not the 1980s
anymore and it would be great to unify
gravity with the other forces of nature
that's a fine thing to think about doing
but it ain't enough
we know more now from thinking about the
challenges of quantum gravity to realize
that the real challenge the real
interest is not in unifying gravity with
the other forces you can play around
with math and try to do that
the real challenge is that gravity seems
to be a different kind of theory it is
not a straightforward Quantum field
Theory there's plenty of reasons to
think that gravity is in some sense
fundamentally non-local
it looks local in the weak field
effective field Theory limit Etc local
in the sense that if you poke the
universe at one point all the
disturbances move away at the speed of
light or less right but in gravity in
quantum gravity you can imagine
wormholes virtual wormholes or all sorts
of weird space-time geometries in black
holes you have the idea that all the
information is somehow encoded at the
Horizon somehow in the black holes
evaporate information travels from the
inside to the outside all of these
non-local things going on adsc of T is
an example of an explicitly non-local
connection between two different kinds
of theories so the challenge the
interest the fun part of quantum gravity
is not in unifying it with the other
forces of nature that's fine let's try
to do that that would have been a Hot
Topic in the 1980s still interesting but
now we have much more subtle
challenging features of quantum gravity
that we would like to explain
so people are trying but you know
there's some fraction of people who are
trying right uh what you will find you
know I've interviewed a whole bunch of
string theorists uh they're they're
honestly string theorists people in that
camp here on mindscape I almost don't
want to forget anyone but I already
mentioned Annie strominger there was
Clifford Johnson Raphael buso data
engelhardt right
um other people Michael dine has worked
on the phenomological side of string
theory and they don't want to call
themselves string theorists and it's not
because they're embarrassed with string
theory it's because you know sometimes
they're doing String Theory sometimes
they're not who cares they're doing
theoretical physics they're trying to
understand the world and the Ultimate
answers we get to how the world Works
might very well end up being inspired by
String Theory but not being string
theory and that's fine and those I think
that that set of activities is still
very exciting how could you not listen
to the podcast I did with Natalie or
Raphael or Andy and not be excited by
what's going on there so I don't think
this is a crisis either you know I think
the quantum gravity is a very weird
thing it's experimentally very very
difficult to think about
um
but we made sort of more progress than
we really have any right to expect
honestly in quantum gravity and maybe we
will continue to do that maybe we'll
continue to get lucky but the fact that
we're not done yet the fact that we
haven't completed it that we haven't
figured out exactly the path from M
Theory to the standard model of particle
physics in my mind is the least
surprising thing in the world that's one
of the reasons why I don't do String
Theory myself I think it is the best
uh most promising route we have to
quantizing gravity compared to all the
other Roots but it's hard it's hard to
make progress on it and I think that
there's other ways that we could think
about so
that's my I know I told you at the
beginning it was going to go on right
but you know you're not forced to do
this you're not there's no test at the
end of it you can listen to it if you
want to so I wanted to talk about those
three
segments those three aspects of physics
that were arguably you know crisis Laden
uh the fact that we have not yet pinned
down the right models for the dark
matter and dark energy the fact that we
have these naturalness problems and we
keep coming up with theories to explain
them but they don't really seem to work
and the whole difficulty of quantum
gravity and trying to find the Right
theory for that
um so with that in mind with that is
background what is the crisis what is
the purported disastrous situation that
physics is in you know I think that I
don't want to be too unfair here but I
think a lot of the if you dig into the
specific arguments given by people who
claim there's a crisis in physics a lot
of the time they come down to other
people aren't working on my favorite
ideas
which is fine like everyone thinks that
like if you if you you only have a
finite lifespan right and if you're a
researcher you only have a finite number
of ideas that you can pursue papers that
you can write Etc and if you you're
going to work on those ideas that you
think are most interesting and promising
and when those ideas turn out to be in
the minority
then you feel like everyone else is
making a mistake why are they doing
things my way why are they doing my
favorite new theory of of whatever I get
that but it's and this is if there's a
lesson to this whole long extended
podcast it's the following
when we're in a situation where we don't
know what the right answer is or we
think that there is a theory that is
better than the physical theories that
we have right now but we don't know
which one it is on the one hand It's
Perfectly Natural to spend your time
working on what you think is the most
promising Way Forward
but if you're honest about the health of
the field as a whole then you should
hope that the field as a whole works on
many different things because you don't
know what the right answer is so if if
anyone is claiming there's a crisis in
physics and you dig down deeply into
their justification for saying that and
it comes down to people are working on
other ideas not the ideas that I like I
wouldn't take that too seriously people
are supposed to work on different ideas
and this whole situation is very hard
because as we've discussed we have a
very good effective field Theory we have
a theory that fits the data very very
well there's some theories that we don't
have pinned down yet like the nature of
the dark matter and so forth and there
we have more than one theory that is
plausibly doing the job
so what do you do in that situation what
is the healthy thing to do
and you know I I was greatly
um impressed in the sense of an
impression was made not that I thought
it was impressive but an impression was
made in a discussion that you can find
online between Richard Feynman and Fred
Hoyle
Feynman you've heard of Fred Hoyle uh
for those of you who don't know was a
very successful astrophysicist and one
of the primary proponents of the steady
state model of the universe as opposed
to the Big Bang model uh but he was a
brilliant guy he just never quite let go
of that steady state model it's hard
this is something you see in science all
the time it's very hard to actually let
go of your favorite Theory even when the
data comes in and says that's not the
way to go this is why progress is made
by people getting older and retiring as
much as it is by people changing their
minds
but the discussion you might think you
know Feynman was super duper successful
loyal was pretty successful but had some
wacky ideas you might think that the
discussion between them would be you
know hoil haranguing Feynman about being
too much in the establishment or
something like that but in fact it was
Feynman
expressing great admiration for Fred
Hoyle and the direction of his
admiration was not in any specific
theory that Hoyle was proposing but the
style that they both used as successful
theoretical physicists because Feynman
points out that Hoyle was just Fearless
about putting forward speculative ideas
speculative new scenarios whereas
Feynman in his own way of thinking about
his own work
preferred to stick very very close to
what we already knew worked he his
self-description I'm not you know
putting words in his mouth he thought of
himself as sort of reformulating things
that we already know work do work better
right and if you think about Feynman
diagrams or the path integral or things
like that that is usually what he did
these are not overthrowing previously
understood theories renormalization
right this understanding theories that
we already have
he had a couple of theories which were
you know speculative but it was
definitely not his usual mode of working
and this is a very interesting
distinction because it continues on
right I mean Murray Gelman byman's
contemporary was much more on the I'm
going to propose a model side of things
but these are both very valid ways of
doing physics you can both take what you
already know and work within those
paradigms and I've written papers like
that you know I've done papers on
calculating things in the microwave
background or large scale structure or
the Bayesian second law of
Thermodynamics I have also done the
other thing proposing new models right
being speculative I propose models about
lorentz violation and quintessence and
modified gravity in the arrow of time
and so forth and you need both right
even if an individual person wants to do
one but not the other the field needs
both and you have to
Soldier on and in different parts
different moments in history one way of
working might turn out to be more
productive and in other moments the
other one might be and you might not
know ahead of time
so we're in a situation now where people
have been
working within the known standard model
and chord theory for a long time to the
extent that
the improvements being made there you
know are naturally going to get slower
and slower like if you're tuning a car
and trying to make it perform better and
better you can spend a lot of time
tuning it and fixing it and whatever but
there is a maximum uh performance that
you're going to reach and we're getting
there we're not there there's still a
lot of work to be done especially when
it comes to the strong interactions in
qcd and so forth there's plenty of
things that we still need to understand
about the good old-fashioned standard
model
but a lot of modern fundamental physics
is on the speculative side because we
have the theory that works we're trying
to go beyond it people propose new ideas
and then they try to test them most of
them are going to fail sorry because
only a few of them can be right but that
doesn't mean you don't need to do it you
have to do it anyway you need to propose
a whole bunch of ideas even knowing that
most of them are going to fail
now there's another kind of worry right
not that people are just proposing a lot
of speculative ideas but they don't like
the actual ideas that are being proposed
the most popular ideas and that's you
know perfectly intellectually
respectable position to have so I don't
think it's intellectually respectable to
be against the fact that particle
physicist fundamental physicists are
proposing a lot of ideas that are
speculative and hard to test that's just
how we have to make progress but the
actual ideas that are being proposed
okay you're absolutely welcome to think
that it's the wrong direction to go in
so let's just quickly dance over some of
the big targets here there is
supersymmetry as I said supersymmetry it
popped up in I think maybe as early as
the late 60s right but certainly in the
70s it became popular it has this nice
feature super symmetry is this symmetry
between bosons and fermions it is both
super highly constrained in the sense
that it is hard to write write down
theories of particle physics that are
actually supersymmetric okay it's much
harder than non-super symmetric theories
that's a very sensible generic feature
of having symmetries in your theory it
constrains what you can do and the other
thing about supersymmetry is it makes
life easier at a calculator not a
calculational level sometimes
calculational level but a mathematical
level in terms of all these Infinities
that you worry about in particle physics
Ken Wilson said we don't have to worry
about them in an effective field Theory
but if your goal is more than an
effective field theory if your goal is a
theory that covers everything then you
have to worry about the ultraviolet
behavior of your theory
physicists will often talk about whether
a certain infrared Theory a theory of
what is going on in the visible Universe
At Low energies Etc has an UltraViolet
completion right maybe you have an
effective field theory that works
perfectly well low energies but maybe
there is no complete theory for which
that is the low energy limit that's an
interesting thing to contemplate and
supersymmetry is absolutely indisputably
helpful in trying to make a well-behaved
ultraviolet Theory that doesn't mean
it's necessarily true but it's helpful
and the more Super symmetry you try to
throw in the more constrained Things
become there's even a maximum amount of
supersymmetry that you can put in your
theory uh once Joe palchinski made the
slightly lighthearted uh claim that if
people doing Loop quantum gravity were
serious they would undergo the following
chain of logic they would say
okay we have a theory of gravity but
it's not very well behaved at high
energies so let's make a super symmetric
version of our Theory that's fine and
still Loop quantum gravity but
supersymmetric and they would look at
all the supersymmetries and they would
go oh you know the way that you could
have the most supersymmetry is if you
were in 11 dimensional space time and
then you would put a compactification of
this 11-dimensional theory on a circle
to make a 10-dimensional theory and you
would find that there are strings in
that 10-dimensional theory and you would
have reinvented String Theory now this
is not exactly a plausible alternative
history especially because one of the
things about Loop quantum gravity is
that it works best in fact it kind of
only works naturally let's say that yeah
you never want to say that something
only works in physics because some
clever person is going to find a way
around it but there's a natural living
place for Loop quantum gravity which is
three plus one dimensional space time
okay I have heard string theorists and
this is you know now I've been
apologizing and defending the status quo
for a very long time you here let me let
me tease the status quo a little bit
there's absolutely an idea that once
you're embedded in the string theory
world you lose touch a little bit with
the real world okay with the world of
three plus one dimensions and the quarks
and leptons that we know about the
string theorists study these 10
dimensional 11-dimensional theories so
much and D brains and rectifications
that they begin to think maybe casually
maybe in moments of weakness they admit
they slip the tongue and and think that
that's right that's clearly correct and
I've heard string theorists criticize
Loop quantum gravity because it only
works in three plus one space-time
dimensions and people had to point out
well that is where we live that is the
actual Universe in which we live you
know there's no obvious empirical
necessity to have to live in 10
Dimensions it's a possibility but we
don't know anyway I tease the string
theorists they're my friends too so
supersymmetry anyway I don't think that
it would necessarily Lead You inevitably
to string Theory but it is a perfectly
obvious thing to try there's a long
history in physics of adding more
symmetries and things get better and it
is phenomenologically interesting you
know you literally double the number of
particles in a super symmetric Theory
from a non-super symmetric Theory
that you have a whole bunch of particles
in the standard model some bosons some
vermions they don't match up with each
other but super symmetry says that every
such part particle has a partner of the
other kind of spin so you have the
double or more the number of particles
in the supersymmetric version of the
standard model the there's various
supersymmetric versions of the standard
model
and it's even because it's con it's
constraining it's even more specific
than that in the phenomenology you can't
in supersymmetric versions of the
standard model just take the Higgs boson
and make a supersymmetric version of it
you need to take multiple versions of
the original Higgs boson you'd add more
Higgs bosons to your regular non-super
symmetric Theory before you
supersymmetrize it and so that's an
interesting feature of the model that
you could test at an accelerator and you
could look at it right you could look
for it we did we haven't found it yet
again it's possible that it's there but
we haven't found it yet but let's be
honest about supersymmetry it's very
very helpful phenomologically it's very
very interesting in terms of predictions
that it made it also could have been
found by now and it's not necessary that
it was found by now both of those things
are simultaneously true I don't want to
be you know too pedantic or whatever but
sometimes people people pretend that one
of those things is true but not the
other it could have been found that it
hasn't been it could still be right
because what happens is you know that
supersymmetry is not manifest in the
real world when you look at the standard
model it by itself is not supersymmetric
you don't see this symmetry lying around
so you have to break the Symmetry just
like brow and on glare and Higgs and and
their friends broke the Symmetry that we
now know is the electric weak symmetry
right you have to somehow spontaneously
break it so that means that there is an
energy scale at which supersymmetry is
broken
and you would predict again typically
normally without working too hard you
would predict that these super partners
that you don't directly see have masses
of roughly that supersymmetry breaking
scale and again if you as I as I try to
convince you for a very long spiel
earlier there was plenty of reason to
think in 70s 80s 90s whatever that there
was something weird going on at the
electro week scale at the scale where
the Higgs boson gets its vacuum
expectation value and that gives masses
to the W bosons and the Z bosons and all
the fermions and that scale is of order
hundreds of gev so there was all the
reason the world if you were a super
super symmetry uh partisan to think that
the scale of supersymmetry breaking
would be near that electroweak scale
maybe a little bit above it okay so that
the effects trickle down and make the
Higgs boson have the mass that it had so
weak scale supersymmetry was a very very
popular
phenomenological prediction
hypothesis I should say and again you
could have seen it by now very very
easily and so you haven't so what does
that mean well it means that there's
there's lots of possibilities but uh two
possibilities suggest themselves very
readily one is that the scale of
supersymmetry breaking and now Imagining
the supersymmetry is still real is it
possible so persimmon tree is true even
though we didn't see it yet yes either
because the scale of supersymmetry is
just a bit higher for some reason maybe
there's some little mini hierarchy
between the supersimmery braking scale
and the electroweak scale so the LHC
which remember is not as high energy as
the SSE would have been just doesn't
have the oomph to get there yet that's
plausible you know you you begin to feel
that you're grasping at straws a little
bit but it's certainly absolutely on the
table as a possibility the other
possibility is that the super symmetry
breaking scale is way up at the Planck
scale that all of the dreams of new
particles and dark matter candidates Etc
at the electric weak scale were just
misguided now if that's true
supersymmetry would not serve as an
explanation for the hierarchy problem
but it could still be true all right
we've lost supersymmetry as an
explanation for the hierarchy problem at
that scale if that's true if you have
what is called high scale supersymmetry
breaking but that it still could be true
right and it's the job of the physicist
to chase down what might be true so I
would say that given that the LHC has
not found supersymmetry yet it is a
hundred percent
the right thing to decrease your
Credence that supersymmetry is right
from what it was let's say in 2005 okay
if you had whatever Credence you had the
fact that supersymmetry has not been
found should by base's law lower your
Credence because there is a prediction
that gave you a chance that you would
have seen it you didn't your Credence
should go down but it shouldn't go down
to zero unless it was Zero already okay
so you just have to be
you just have to be careful you just
have to really think it through so I'm
I'm perfectly happy if people have lost
their uh gunjones about super symmetry
but you can say that it's gone or it's
been ruled out or anything like that let
me say just one more word about the
hierarchy problem because I did mention
it before I alluded to it before but
maybe let me fill in a little bit
um to me the fact that the hierarchy
problem didn't have some doesn't have
some obvious solution that popped in our
faces when we turned on the LHC
might I'm kind of cryptically optimistic
that this means something really big is
going on okay so what I mean by that is
you know we already have the
cosmological constant problem and
there's no easy way to solve that we've
been banging our heads about uh against
the wall about that for a long time
there is the anthropic principle in the
Multiverse but
that doesn't really work for the
hierarchy problem you can easily imagine
laws of physics that are compatible with
intelligent life without having the
Higgs boson be much lighter than the
plank scale so that's a different kind
of thing you know in some sense we have
no good anthropic solutions for the
hierarchy problem like we do for the
cosmological constant problem so people
really thought that they were going to
find a whole bunch of new particles at
the LHC to help explain the hierarchy
problem whether those were
supersymmetric particles or particles
from extra Dimensions or strong Dynamics
or whatever one thing or another would
work and it they're not there yet maybe
they'll be there tomorrow again that's
always possible but let's imagine that
they're not let's imagine that we run
the Lac for several years at higher
energies and higher intensities and we
don't see anything
then you have two possibilities right
one is there is no solution to the
hierarchy problem we just got lucky
the Higgs boson mass or the expectation
value the Higgs boson if you want to
think about it that way just is much
lower than the plank scale it's a brute
fact that we can accept but we don't
need to explain you know we've talked a
few times on the podcast with
philosophers about what it means to
explain something with Tony lambroso and
with uh Simon Deo and most recently
Katie Elliott a little bit uh maybe
there is no explanation for this it's
just a brute fact that's a possibility
but the other possibility is that
something way more dramatic and profound
is going on right
um you know when you say you have these
expectations from effective field theory
for the magnitude of the Higgs mass and
the cosmological constant and they're
way wrong then it is very easy to say
okay maybe something is wrong about your
intuition about effective field Theory
that's easy to say but what is wrong
about it and it could be something deep
about the nature of space-time or
Quantum field Theory or something like
that like I said I've been trying to
think of things I haven't come up with
anything very plausible yet nothing not
even the least publishable unit which
academics like to talk about uh no no
theory that even really came close to
working there but that's an exciting
possibility because Quantum field theory
is so robust and so Universal and so
kind of hard to break that any way that
we can get a handle on ways in which our
Quantum field Theory intuition just
breaks down uh is potentially very very
interesting on the flip side it's a sort
of negative result right I mean if you
just say well here's a calculation that
doesn't work
okay that doesn't tell me what does work
it doesn't give me much guidance as to
how to go next so I think that's
something to keep an eye on for future
progress but it's hard to know what
direction that future progress will be
in
so I don't think there's any reason to
be like harshly negative about super
super symmetry Etc
um it was a very obvious thing to try
now you could
be a little harsh about the precise
amount of effort that has been put into
supersymmetry I'll get to that in a
little bit let me let's just put that on
the table for a bit uh string theory is
obviously related to supersymmetry now
String Theory as I said works best if
you have supersymmetry as part of it so
you get super string theory
you can absolutely have string theory
and have super symmetry be broken at a
very high scale right High scale super
symmetry breaking at the playing scale
completely invisible to us at particle
accelerators so the fact that you didn't
see supersymmetric particles yet at the
LHC should lower your Credence in
supersymmetry but shouldn't separately
lower your Credence and string theory
right it lowers your Credence and
strength Theory because it lowers your
Credence in super symmetry it doesn't do
it again it doesn't sort of act twice
String Theory doesn't really care if you
have new particles at the LHC uh as I
said about the history of string theory
it kind of fell in our laps and it
absolutely has not made direct
connection with observation and so I
think that it's both true that it makes
perfect sense that we put a lot of
effort into it you know when you get
something nice dropped into your laps
then by all means take advantage of it
uh it's also perfectly valid to say you
know the progresses has not been what we
hoped let's broaden our Horizons and
think about other things you know I will
say that the other options on the table
are for good reason just not as
attractive it's not sociology okay it's
not personality conflicts it's not
people trying to squelch the brave
Rebels or anything like that there are
physics-based reasons why people like
string theory when it comes to quantum
gravity
um just to sketch out what is in the
back of the Mind of a lot of working
string theorists you know as I said
string theory is a finite theory of
quantum gravity you know you can do your
scattering predictions Etc you get
finite answers that's semi-miraculous
when it comes to quantum gravity
the other approaches you know there's
probably many approaches out there I
shouldn't speak for all of them at once
but the popular alternative approaches
to quantum gravity generally start by
trying to do just gravity okay they're
literally taking gravity as special and
trying to quantize it and that's again a
perfectly natural thing to try but it's
also Perfectly Natural to expect it
won't work because if you think about
what happens when you try to quantize
gravity that is to say take some
classical Theory and apply it the rules
of quantum mechanics do it and convert
it into a quantum mechanical Theory uh
whatever your approach is you still have
this wilsonian distinction between what
happens in the infrared at long
distances uh low energies and what
happens in the ultraviolet short
distances High Energies
and the structure of known physics is
that there's really no regime in which
what happens in the ultraviolet to
gravity is independent of what happens
to other things okay I don't know if
that was kind of a tortured sentence but
you know that you don't only have
gravity in the world you have all the
other fields of nature in the world Etc
and you know that they act as sources
for Gravity right ordinary matter and
energy and radiation create
gravitational fields so when you have a
theory that has both gravity in it and
other things in that ultraviolet regime
in that high energy regime where
everything is problematic and you're
trying to invent a new theory of what's
going on there's no subset of that
theory where you can turn on gravity and
turn on everything else and get sensible
answers everything is important in the
ultraviolet everything is you know
energetic and bumping into each other
and everything kind of matters that's
part of why String Theory seems a little
miraculous because because it is a
theory of everything it includes not
only gravity but all the other stuff in
the universe and everything sort of
miraculously
conspires in the ultraviolet to give you
a finite answer so string theorists look
at people trying to just quantize
gravity and they like what what are you
even trying that there's there's no
reason to think that that is going to
work obviously that doesn't imply that
string theory is right I'm just trying
to give you a little bit of the reason
why
the physics Community thinks that string
theory is so much more
uh promising than other approaches it's
not a hundred percent but it's a little
bit of a reason so you know should we be
critical of the fact that there was so
much effort in string theory over the
last few decades even though it is not
still connected with observations you
know I have mixed feelings about that I
think that string theory has made
progress like we've learned a lot about
the structure of string theory itself
and we've learned a lot of lessons that
sort of apply to quantum gravity more
broadly even if String Theory itself
turns out not to be on the right track
right things like as I said holography
and complementarity and black hole
information and things like that all
these insights as far as I can see came
from people who were either string
theorists or string theory adjacent I
don't know of any particular insights
that came from non-string Theory
approaches that have been that
influential the one possible counter
example there is holography itself
holography the idea that the information
contained in a black hole and maybe more
broadly
can be thought of as spread out over the
horizon of the black hole rather than
scattered through the interior so
something non-local and lower
dimensional in uh arguably the first
person to put forward that idea was
Gerardo tuft uh he did it before saskin
did but suskin did in a way that was
much clearer to the rest of the
community in much more dramatic so and
independently also so they both get
credit for it but a tuft was not really
working within string theory he has
worked within String Theory but he was
actually you know ultimately if you dig
down he was thinking about the
foundations of quantum mechanics he's
interested in the foundations of quantum
mechanics and that he had some discrete
models and that led him to this uh
holographic idea
but the development of those ideas has
largely been within the string theory
context so that's one hand one side of
the story I think that it we've gotten
some benefit from thinking so hard about
string theory on the other hand I I do
think as I you know alluded to in my
jokey story before I do think that it
has had an effect on the physics
Community which is not entirely saludory
um there's a degenerate the early
generation of string theorists if you're
talking about you know the David grosses
and Ed wittens Etc of the world those
people grew up
trying to fit the data right you can
find papers by Ed Whitton on Dark Matter
candidates and predictions for astronomy
or papers by David Gross obviously in
qcd which was kind of a big deal in
fitting the data Etc so even though they
were working on string theory they were
absolutely familiar with the idea that
the ultimate goal is to fit the data is
to come up with explanations for the
real world and there's a whole
generation Maybe by now two generations
of young string theorists who have only
ever done string theory and I'm thinking
of string theory now in the broadest
possible context where you know people
who work on ads CFT and holography and
all that stuff counter-string theorists
even if they would know a string
scattering diagram if it bit them in the
nose Okay the thing is that they're
working in their little toy model space
where they have exactly solvable or at
least you know very tractable situations
like ads CFT that they can work like
work in they can take these D brains and
they can overlap them blah blah blah
blah and they never need to worry
about constraints from I don't know
electric weak Precision tests or big
bang nuclear synthesis or whatever
because they're not even in that regime
they're not trying to explain the actual
world they're saying that oh yeah
someday we'll get to the actual world
but right now we're trying to understand
the features of uh supersymmetric
Quantum field theories or D brains or
adsc of t or whatever
and I have very very mixed feelings
about this I think I would personally be
much happier if in addition to playing
with those models people kept front and
center the idea that the ultimate goal
is to explain the world of our
experience the world we actually see and
there's absolutely a subset of the
stringy community that kind of poo-poos
that idea at this point right we're
learning about the fundamental nature of
string theory and Quantum field Theory
not the dirty particularities of our
world I think that that is something
that you can worry about I think that
you know you got to keep your eyes on
the prize uh there was you know for a
long time in the 80s and 90s A A
thriving string phenomenology movement
there's still people doing it of course
but maybe the movement is a little bit
less thriving than it used to be because
it turns out to be really hard
um but it's you know there's been almost
a backlash or a backfire effect I guess
where a lot of string theorists will
sort of think it's just not their job to
try to explain the messy particularities
of the real world and again I think that
that's that is something I think you can
legitimately worry about the real world
should be
the ultimate goal here and if you
remember when we had Brian Greene on the
podcast Brian is a very thoughtful guy
and he was very honest and he says he
absolutely can see a possible future
history where string theory is only done
in Mass departments right where because
people have not
been focused on explaining the data in
the real world it becomes more I mean
you do learn a lot about math by doing
String Theory Edward won the fields
battle which is the highest mathematical
prize you can win
um and that might be fine that might be
what happens but there is still also an
ambition that string theory will
actually explain something about the
real world so I think that's a difficult
conversation to have within physics
departments people don't like to be told
that they're ignoring the real world
um and so that's a that's a tricky thing
to get into and I'll talk a little bit
more about that in a second but so I
mentioned supersymmetry string theory
and the last one I'll talk about very
quickly is the Multiverse
again I've talked about the Multiverse a
lot so I don't need to go into great
detail but just to emphasize things that
I always emphasize the current interest
in the Multiverse to the extent that uh
it is it exists is not something that
just came out of physicist saying wow
wouldn't it be cool that there's like a
Multiverse there are all these universes
that's never been the motivation you
have pre-existing theories namely
inflationary cosmology and string theory
and both of these theories are motivated
by trying to explain features of the
observed world in the case of inflation
the fact that the cosmological Universe
we observe is spatially flat and very
smooth on large scales in the case of
string theory the fact that there is
gravity and also gauge theories and also
fermions in the universe that and they
all have to fit together into some
consistent framework that was the
original motivation for string theory
three and then you follow your nose you
try to understand very well the
predictions of these theories and you
end up predicting a cosmological
Multiverse at least in a large fraction
of parameter space let's put it that way
maybe you can avoid it I don't even know
but or maybe it's necessary maybe it's
just optional but it's certainly not
that hard to get a cosmological
Multiverse in the combination of
inflation plus string theory
you could also get a cosmological
Multiverse without inflation restraint
Theory but its inflation string theory
that sort of put it in front of you and
you gotta deal with it somehow you can't
just ignore the possibility okay and
there are those who will say that even
contemplating the Multiverse is
anti-scientific because science should
be about what we observe and if you have
a theory that relies on things that you
can never observe that you can never see
even in principle right because they're
outside are observable cosmological
Horizon then what you're doing might be
philosophy but it's not science that
would be the argument
I don't think that argument is right at
all and I said so said why many times
but let me very quickly review it
because it's relevant to this discussion
uh the thing about the Multiverse is
that it does matter to just to say that
the existence of other universes is not
directly observable therefore it's not
scientific I think is pretty obviously
clearly wrong it's a standard example of
bad philosophy and scientists are not
always well trained at doing philosophy
well the point is that it matters to
Scientific practice whether or not there
is a Multiverse right the Multiverse is
something that could be true it does not
fit in to the things that Carl popper
was imagining when he invented the
falsifiability Criterion for separating
science from non-science what he was
against are theories that really don't
say anything that could be twisted to
fit any possible empirical thing that
happens in the world the Multiverse is
not that the Multiverse absolutely says
something it says that the Universe out
there far away has different physical
conditions than ours okay that is
indisputably a thing that is being said
a very precise and concrete it is not
directly observable that's an issue that
we have to deal with but it doesn't make
it non-scientific and here's the thing
the practice of science as we've
discussed involves hypothesizing
different models and trying to use them
to best fit the data that we do observe
one of the puzzles we have for example
is why is the cosmodial constant so much
smaller than the Planck scale well maybe
it's because there's a Multiverse and
the cosmological constant is just not a
fundamental parameter it takes on
different values from place to place and
there's a selection effect that puts us
in a region where the cosmological
constant is small or maybe there is no
Multiverse and there is a single unique
predictive theory that tells you what
the cosmotional constant is both of
these possibilities are absolutely on
the table as of right now so as a
theoretical physicist who is interested
in this problem what are you going to do
how are you going to spend your time you
don't know which of these possibilities
is right so imagine that you had an
oracle or God or something who told you
indisputably that there really is a
Multiverse and that there really are
regions of our space-time where values
of parameters like the cosmotional
constant take on different numerical
values okay
then you would be really dumb if you
just insisted on saying well I'm still
going to work on a theory that predicts
the cosmological constant taking on a
unique value you've just been told that
that's wrong okay so of course there is
no such Oracle there is no one who knows
the right answer about this but the
point is that the work you do as a
theoretical physicist will depend on
whether or not there are regions far
away where the cosmological constant
takes on different values it matters
you can't just say well I can't see
those other universes therefore I will
ignore them they play an explanatory
role in what we actually do observe and
this is not like tricky or subtle this
is why it's a little frustrating for
people like me like it's not that hard
to wrap your brain around this you can't
directly see the other regions of the
universe but they nevertheless play a
role in explaining what we do see
therefore it is part of science you know
they're much like quarks and gluons you
don't see them directly either or
virtual particles or whatever your
favorite example is there's all sorts of
examples of things you don't see
directly but nevertheless play a role in
explaining what it is that we do see the
Multiverse is just like that
so I don't think I don't buy the
argument that the Multiverse is
intrinsically anti-scientific in any way
I think that's just wrong-headed and bad
philosophy as I've said before now
there's a more subtle version of this
argument that I should give some credit
to it's that if you really have a
Multiverse where you know many many an
infinite number of things happen Okay
let's put it that way an infinite number
of regions that are all their separate
universes and many different things
happen then it becomes hard to make
predictions okay even probabilistic
predictions because now the argument is
not just well there's things I don't see
I don't like it now the argument is
you've lost predictive power because
Infinity divided by Infinity is
ill-defined okay because you're saying
well I have an infinite number of
regions of the universe
in an infinite number of them the
cosmological constant takes on a certain
value and in another infinite number of
them it takes on a different value how
can you possibly predict what it is that
you expect to see
parenthetically the way that these
predictions are made is typically by
assuming that we are typical in their
set of all possible observers I think
that is a very very bad silly assumption
but that's a that's a topic for another
podcast but anyway the the
straightforward mathematical worry is
that you just can't calculate anything
even in principle because it's Infinity
divided by Infinity uh that's the um
argument that people like Paul
steinhardt put forward saying that the
current version of Eternal inflation
should not be taken seriously as a
scientific hypothesis
now that's a tricky one because that
there you have to say well maybe
you know the thing about Infinity
divided by Infinity is sometimes it's
just completely ill-defined if you just
say those words you can't actually
pinpoint what the answer is but in
practice for specific examples of
infinity minus infinity maybe there is a
perfectly unique well-defined procedure
for turning that into a well-defined
number right uh and in the case of the
cosmological Multiverse you just don't
know this is called The cosmological
Measure problem in Multiverse study
circles and so what people like
steinhardt are saying is you can't ever
solve the measure problem
and with people like me are saying is
how do you know that I mean maybe you
can't solve it maybe you just have to
work harder it's very hard because we
don't have direct experimental guidance
but I don't think that the answer is to
put your head in the sand and say well
you just can't do it let's just think of
other theories if I had a convincing
argument I it's hard to imagine what a
convincing argument would be but if I
had a convincing argument that this sort
of infinity divided by Infinity problem
was literally unsolvable then I would
take that as a very strong argument that
you should not take the Multiverse
seriously but I haven't seen any such
argument and again I don't even know
what it would be like it might be hard
to figure out how to regularize this
particular limit of infinity divided by
Infinity but and I'm not that convinced
by any of the current proposals that
have been put forward but the fact is
there have been proposals that have been
put forward this is this is a question
that you try to solve and you see
whether you can answer it you don't just
insist that it is unsolvable question
so anyway I think that you can argue
about the amount of effort that has been
put into supersymmetry String Theory the
Multiverse that's a perfectly okay thing
to discuss and to argue about but none
of these are pursued out of bad faith or
conspiracy theories or you know some
powerful person decides what is allowed
to be studied and what is not they're
pursued because they're good ideas and I
hope I've at least given you an insight
into why the people who pursue them
think that they are good ideas those
people could be wrong that's always
possible but they're trying their best
you know every individual scientist
wants to be right I don't know if that's
a dramatic you know wild claim these
days but the reason why people are
working on these things is because they
think that they're plausibly correct
truly new good ideas if you had an
alternative to these ideas that had all
of the promising features that the
existing idea have would be very very
welcomed it turns out that it's hard to
come up with truly good new ideas we're
trying some people are trying right but
it is hard to do progress is slow nature
is not being helpful at the moment so
that's the situation we're in okay
I want to wrap up I've been going too
long I did predict it right you can at
least say I made a falsifiable
prediction that I would I did I promise
you I recorded the intro to this podcast
before doing the podcast but I knew I
had a lot to say and I knew that I would
indulge Myself by talking a lot about
known things uh about the standard model
and things like that but the reason why
is not just complete self-indulgence I
really want to
Focus the idea that there are reasons
why modern physicists think about things
the way they do okay they don't they're
not just being lazy or group thinky or
whatever there's physics reasons why the
currently most
popular models are the most popular
models but there are also the thing I
want to wrap up with perfectly
legitimate concerns about how to handle
the weird situation that we find
ourselves in by the weird situation we
find ourselves in what I mean is as I
said at the beginning we have theories
that fit all the data
nature is not giving us
clear precise experimental guidance
about where to go from here
and that is a very very tricky situation
as an intellectual Endeavor okay when
you're really just left to your thoughts
you have the data like the data keep
coming in the experimentalists don't
blame the experimentalist it's not their
fault that they haven't found data that
is in Wild uh contradiction to our
expectations it's Nature's fault it's an
experimentalists are doing amazing
things and you know again as I keep
saying maybe tomorrow we will find such
a
um
difference between Theory and experiment
but right now we don't have it so we are
left to our thoughts in terms of how to
go beyond it and when you do have all
sorts of new data coming in and you
they're all surprising you don't know
how to fit them together and it's all a
puzzle and it's all a lot of fun then
you can have people working on different
approaches and as soon as a new piece of
data comes in people's opinions can
wildly change about which approach is
more promising okay like you know when
you say well what if parody is not
conserved and then they go out and find
that it's not conserved and oh okay well
then everyone changes what they're
working on right
when the data is not flowing in those
rapid changes of Direction driven by new
experimental input are not there
so you relying on people and their
judgments about what is interesting and
what is promising maybe string theory is
the way to quantize gravity maybe it's
Loop quantum gravity maybe it's causal
triangulations or something different
than that
all the decisions about which to pursue
who to hire and there's a lot of levels
of decisions here right not only who do
you hire on your faculty but who do you
teach what do you teach your graduate
students what funding do you give who
gets grants who gets to have a
conference and who gets to get together
with their friends I mean it would be
perfectly legitimate to say you know
progress in my subfield would have been
faster if we'd gotten more money to
pursue it yeah you know that's always a
possibility the trick is you have to
convince the rest of the community that
your approach is actually promising so
when data is not guiding you and when
you just lean on human people deciding
what is promising and what is not biases
can creep in everyone is biased right I
mean part of the bias is very simple and
straightforward and obvious work on the
thing that everyone else is working on
right because when you're a young person
there's you know there's always going to
be some Real Genius doing whatever they
want fine but most people are not
Geniuses most people are you know who
are trying to be professional academics
they're in grad school they're post-docs
or whatever they're trying their best
they know that most people in their
positions are not ultimately going to be
tenured faculty members there is a very
narrowing pipeline along the way from
undergrad to grad to postdoc to faculty
okay so you can kind of puzzle away at
your own little problems and put them on
the archive and even get them published
and if nobody cares and what you've done
it's going to be hard to get hired or to
get funding or whatever there is you
know part of the strategy you have to
pursue if you want to keep doing physics
for a living is to work on things that
are on the one hand new and exciting but
on the other hand relatable to the other
people who are already out there so this
is just a very natural again it's not
evil or pernicious it's just a very
natural feature of the system you know
what are you going to tell people who
are hiring
hire people who haven't done anything
interesting you're not gonna that's not
a very plausible strategy you can't just
say like hire everybody there's a fixed
number of jobs out there okay and
there's a very natural therefore bias
towards whatever theories are occurrant
at the time
but there's another there's a more
subtle aspect of exactly this problem
which is that okay let's say that you're
perfectly fair and rational okay you're
the hiring committee some University
you're going to hire a new theoretical
physicist and you know perfectly well
that this particular Theory might be
right this other approach might be right
people tend to do either one approach or
the other
you're trying to figure out who to hire
and you think that there's you know a 90
chance that approach a is on the right
track and only a 10 chance it is
approach B is on the right track
you might argue or you might naively
expect that 90 of the time you should
hire a person working within project a
which has a 90 chance of being right and
10 of the time hire a person working
within Project B here's the problem with
that you don't hire 10 people you don't
hire 100 people or even 10 people you
hire a person every
five years at best maybe every 10 years
or longer depending how big your
department is you don't get a lot of
chances at the prize okay you have to
hire someone and if you're a department
like most departments where probably you
know there's a big pipeline squeeze
bottleneck between being postdoc and
being Junior faculty but most Junior
faculty will eventually get tenure so
you hire someone they're 30 years old
you're going to be with them for the
next 40 years right so there's a
so a conservatism Creeps in is what I'm
getting at you don't get to hire many
people when you hire them you might very
well be stuck with them as colleagues
for the next four decades and so it
would be nice to take some take some
chances take a shot here and there try
you know roll the dice a little bit
but there is a natural conservatism that
Creeps in because you don't have that
many chances to hire theoretical
physicists and you want to be relevant
to an important department
uh going forward and you know maybe you
can say well a very good person will
start off in
Paradigm B but then eventually realize
that it's not working and switch to
Paradigm a
sure that's possible but it doesn't it
very often doesn't happen I don't want
to say that it doesn't often happen but
I should say that it often doesn't
happen how about that right people stick
with the the basic Theory the basic
framework in which they've been working
for a long time the people who believe
in the steady state Theory kept working
on the steady state theory for decades
after we discovered the cosmic microwave
background okay
so what happens is that because you have
individual departments doing the hiring
and they don't get to hire many people
if there is a feeling in the community
that one approach approach a has a 90
chance of being right and approach B is
a 10 chance of being right roughly
speaking you hire a hundred percent
people working in approach a that's not
always true because people are quirky
and etc etc but there absolutely is
going to be an enhancement of the bias
against people working in approach B
it's exactly if this is very familiar
from voting theory in a democracy right
if you say okay we want to give everyone
equal representation but you have a
bunch of states or counties or whatever
where there's 90 percent of people
voting for party a and ten percent of
the people voting for party B every
single state or every single County or
whatever
elects a representative from party a you
don't get 10 to party B in Parliament
okay the same kind of thing is happening
when you hire theoretical physicists so
as a field
it would be nice if we could give more
representation I think to alternative
ideas I would completely agree with that
critique of the field as a whole
in my mind when I have what I'm talking
about alternative ideas now
I'm not talking about people wandering
in off the street with their Theory of
Everything I'm talking about people who
have come up you know understand all of
modern physics very very well have done
the work have made a clear and
conscientious anxious decision that a
particular minority approach is the best
way forward and are doing their best
right within that tradition I I do think
that we have a failure of creating a
mechanism for supporting and nurturing
those kind of alternative ideas and I
think that's a shame and some people by
the way
just don't want to
have any support for alternative ideas
they think that they more or less know
the Right Way Forward uh you know I I
started the thought experiment by saying
you know imagine that you're perfectly
rational and you distribute your
credences a lot of people distribute
their credences 99.9 on one thing and
0.01 on everything else so that also
makes it hard uh but what I'm trying to
get across is there are a bunch of
structural reasons why physics
departments tend to be conservative and
they conservative in the sense that
they're going to hire people who are
working in the areas that are sort of
the sure things rather than the gambles
and the same thing goes for funding
agencies and prize committees and so
forth uh Academia in general not just
physics departments there's a lot of
structural reasons why things are
conservative
and I do think that's a problem I mean
you even see it in institutions like the
perimeter Institute which is one of the
world's greatest physics institutes
right now but when it started out it was
much quirkier you know at least Mullen
was there and fotini Marco Polo and a
bunch of people and they were doing Loop
quantum gravity and weird approaches to
the foundations of quantum mechanics and
as it grew and became more respectable
they they turned into one of the world's
great physics institutions as I said but
they also became much more just
mainstream and ordinary it's a part of
the life cycle of a physics department
or Institute you have a Plucky band of
rebels and they kind of equilibrate and
they become more normal and traditional
and you can't blame them can't blame
that particular Institute because
they're just trying to be a good physics
Institute right and then their little
part that they play turns out overall to
make it harder and harder for small
idiosyncratic research program items to
flourish you know there are people who
have tenure you know or senior people
and they can work on their own quirky
little ideas right that's part of the
idea of tenure is that you're supposed
to be shielded from the pressure to
conform to everybody else's standards
but guess what in a physics context
which is the one I'm familiar with two
things happen number one you would like
to have funding if you would like to get
a grant uh to pay your summer salary to
pay your travel expenses to pay for your
new computer to pay for your graduate
students and postdocs and it's harder to
get that Grant I I know because not not
from applying for Grants but from being
on the grant giving out committees the
grant giving out committees that I've
been on are if you had you been on them
you would actually be really impressed
by how hard people try to do the right
thing like it's kind of like you so you
hear stories about juries
um that go along the same directions
like there's always terrible counter
examples but really people take their
responsibilities pretty seriously and
they do want to support young people
they want to support uh daring ideas Etc
but it's just easier to give support to
the things that are kind of
sure things right or at least the most
likely thing to pay off in the eyes of
the rest of the community
so that's one thing that happens and the
other thing that happens is and this
absolutely happens to me like you might
have as a senior person some quirky
ideas that you think are interesting and
fun but the mainstream doesn't really uh
agree with your attitude on but you need
students and you have students whether
you need them or not they come to you as
graduate students and would like to work
on projects and those students need to
get jobs you might be a senior person
you might be fine in your job but
they're at the beginning of their career
and you can tell them and I do
if you do this kind of thing it might be
fun and exciting but it'll be hard to
get a job doing it and then they can
make a educated decision about what to
do but oftentimes what they very very
sensibly want to do is you know please
let me work on things that will allow me
to be continually employed as a
physicist okay
when you're a graduate student that's
not the time to take these giant risks
unless you're the singular genius in
which case good for you but for most of
us
you got to be able to work in ways that
other people recognize the value of your
contribution and that's you know it's
not again it's not evil right it's not
it's not people trying to stamp down
descend or anything it's just if I'm
hiring post Docs
I'm going to want to hire someone who I
can work with
that's not irrational or unreasonable so
if someone has their new weird take on
things that I have just no interest in
it's very unlikely that since I you know
rarely get to hire postdocs at all that
I'm gonna spend my rare postdoc position
on someone who I'm not going to be able
to work with right it's the system it's
the structure that forces you in this
direction it's not uh perniciousness or
evil or some conspiracy theory so even
as a senior person if you want to you
know work with students and and put them
on the track to success you are nudged
in the mainstream kind of Direction
whatever that mainstream is so it just
turns out to be really really hard in
the current system to say you know here
is a minority here's an unlikely shot
no one else thinks it's promising I
think maybe it has a chance let's put
our precious finite resources into it so
that I think I don't think that's a
crisis but I do think that it is
something that is a failure or a
shortcoming let's put it that way of the
current system I think that we
absolutely need a mechanism to support
diverse approaches and it's again it's
very hard to do because I mean it would
be hard for me to say okay let's hire
someone working on bond or working on
Loop quantum gravity I don't think that
those approaches are very promising but
I do think that they're serious you know
I think that they're like Tim Maudlin
when we had him on the podcast he said
look I don't he's very anti-everrate but
he does think that it's a serious
approach it should be it should be
pursued by somebody even though not by
him so I think that we need a better way
of recognizing that kind of thing we
need a better way of separating out here
is the approach we think is actually
promising here is the set of complete
crackpot theories but here in between is
a set of approaches that I don't think
are personally promising but they are
serious and I could be wrong
therefore we should put some effort into
supporting them
I have no idea how to actually make this
happen I'm not the boss of physics
um but I do you know I want to be at
least a little bit fair I'm giving this
very very long spiel trying to explain
why physics is the way it is why it's
not really crisis but I also do want to
recognize that it's not perfect
it absolutely could be improved and
probably this is not just a deal with
physics right this is probably a much
broader
feature of Academia whether it's
economics or philosophy or history or
whatever there are bandwagons there are
mainstream views people with their
Plucky minority views have a tough time
getting through and we all know stories
of the Plucky minority view that turns
out to Triumph in the end those are the
very very rare stories to be clear most
Plucky minority views remain minority
views they become less Plucky over time
and eventually they fade away and you
don't hear their stories so it's hard
to maintain the thriving and robust and
diverse intellectual ecosystem I wish we
could do better than that does that rise
to the level of a crisis no I don't
think it really does I mean maybe 50
years from now if we're still stuck with
the core Theory then we might talk about
crises in a more uh down to earth you
know uh this is a real issue kind of way
but as I you know maybe this came across
or maybe I need to say it more
explicitly it is true that the core
Theory works very well and this is kind
of frustrating but there's no shortage
of open questions that seem to be
plausibly answerable what is the dark
matter does the dark energy evolve or
not uh what happens in black hole
information Theory we didn't even
mention why are there more baryons and
anti-barians what is the origin of
cosmic magnetic fields uh is there
unification of the known forces all
these things perfectly good questions
the hierarchy problem the fact that it
is not solved at the LHC I mean that
is the not very specific guidance as I
said but maybe it's a hint maybe it's
nudging us uh and also things come from
out of the blue right you know the my
particular response to the difficulty in
coming up with plausible models that fit
the data in modern fundamental physics
has been to back up right to step back
look at the foundations of things
rethink how we think about quantum
mechanics and Quantum field Theory and
the emergence of space-time and I
certainly absolutely want to fit the
data you know I absolutely want all of
our speculations about quantum mechanics
and gravity and immersion space time to
end up with testable experimental
predictions I'm also you know perfectly
well aware that that may or may not
happen I can't just insist on it right
but you gotta try you got to keep it in
the back of your mind as that's the
ultimate goal and you have to keep
asking those questions so it's
completely possible to me that even with
just the current information we have a
theory radical breakthrough can really
change our fortunes uh dramatically if I
if we were actually able to come up with
a theory that went from everettian Bare
Bones Quantum State and Hilbert space to
emergent space time to some particular
prediction about
um the fluctuations from the early
universe that we see in the microwave
background or Lorenz invariance
violations or you know something else
like that everything could change you'd
never know so
this is what we signed up for you know
we're trying our best nature never
promised to be kind to us it's not
because we're Dumber you know the people
doing theoretical physics today are just
as smart as the people doing it 50 or
100 or 500 years ago we have to take
what nature gives us and we're trying to
do that I do think we could be better at
nurturing Plucky minority approaches
hopefully uh other people will you know
think about that and try to come up with
clever ways of doing it I'm not like a
build an institution kind of guy that's
that's not my strong suit myself but I
do hope I do wish that there were more
ways where people could pursue
especially in a situation where progress
is slow we're making progress in
fundamental physics we we've come up
with several wonderful ideas but it's
nowhere near the pace it was 100 years
ago right you just gotta face that
that's a fact and in that situation
where progress is slower than it was
before that's the time to roll the dice
a little bit to take some chances uh uh
everyone every older theoretical
physicist has a story about how when
they were younger they had a cool idea
and they went to their mentors or their
senior people and said here's my cool
idea and they were told why the cool
idea wouldn't work and they said oh okay
I didn't know that you're right you're
very wise and very smart and then five
years later someone else actually wrote
the cool idea and figure out how to make
it work okay everyone has that story I
certainly do
it's so easy in physics to say why an
idea won't work it is harder to say yeah
you know I think it won't work but let's
pursue it anyway let's see let's uh you
know
um Alan Guth when he wrote his first
paper on inflationary cosmology had a
model which clearly didn't work and he
publishes the paper and says look I know
this doesn't work but maybe someone will
fix it and of course someone did and it
went forward that's a hard thing to do I
hope that we can become better at that
I'm completely optimistic about the
future of physics but I do think that we
can do even better than we're doing
right now I think we have to be you know
this is not a time to be closed-minded
to circle the wagons it's a time to be
expansive and think about good ideas
take them seriously and who knows we
might have a breakthrough that makes the
second half of the 21st century just as
exciting as the first half of the 20th
century was
[Music]
thank you
la la la
[Music]